Joe welcome to the show Tim thank you so
much buddy I'm so excited to finally
have you here so thanks for flying out
of course my pleasure here we are in
Tejas and where to begin I mean we've
had the opportunity to get to know each
other over the last while which has been
super fun I've had some unique peak
experiences which I'll leave nebulous
just so everyone's really uncomfortable
with that statement and where to begin
we were talking about this I was having
excessive numbers of macchiatos earlier
when I was watching you eat your french
toast and I think the question to start
with is what is your first memory of
causing trouble or getting into struggle
well let's see to go back I think it
would probably be around 2nd grade his
second grade well you have to understand
when I was young I was really into art
and he's into drawing and around the
second grade the Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles came out right like big deal big
deal I was totally hooked Donatello
Michelangelo Raphael everybody like I
was I was in it and so I started drawing
them and I just had such a good time
drawing them I would show them to my
classmates I remember in the second
grade and my classmates started to want
to buy them for me
and so I would mount them on this like
really special poster board and I'd come
in a class and like I would be selling
these for the total of $1 if you want to
get a big one I would sell you the
bigger ones for $2 and so I was having a
ball doing what I loved making drawings
cost me some like making extra you know
allowance every week and with dollars a
lot of money when your second big deal
it's a big deal and so I at one point
that it's my teacher pulls me aside and
she does I need to talk to you and she
begins to explain to me that students
were so interested in these drawings
that they were asking their parents for
extra lunch money and their parents were
like what are you next to a lunch money
for and they traced it back to me and
they the teacher shut me down
ah you can't be doing this alright so
already signs of looming misbehavior
yeah and and signs of you know spotting
an opportunity and doing something about
entrepreneurship yeah yeah it was also
you know you could say my first brush
with regulation yeah first brush that
that may or may not come in handy later
maybe and where were you at the time
just place us geographically where did
you grow up my parents are from New York
what my grandfather's heritage back in
Italy in Ireland
grandfather's in Brooklyn parents grew
up in Long Island moved to Georgia right
before they had me so I grew up in the
deep south and I was in you know the
town of Lawrenceville which is next to
Snellville which is near Lilburn which
is not far from Norcross which is kind
of close to Atlanta so if you went you
know an hour in one direction you'd be
in you know farm fields and you know
horse ranches and um it'd be you know it
was it was it was the south mm-hmm you
know in every kind of way so you're
selling these drawings now where did
that impulse come from and I asked
because I've had a chance to spend some
time with your dad awesome guy it's true
we were together at a date with destiny
event and you had the very good idea of
basically creating animal house by
renting a house together on Joe B&B
otherwise known as Airbnb and your dad's
awesome a also seems to be very
entrepreneurial so that's why I'm asking
I'm not implying it came straight from
your dad but could you maybe talk about
that and then also what we're what were
some defining characteristics of your
childhood well certainly both my parents
including my dad were very
entrepreneurial they both worked for
themselves growing up so I had this you
know environment where I saw my parents
forging their own paths
sort of their success was fully
dependent on how hard they worked and
how ambitious they were in their their
careers of what they were doing and my
dad certainly was entrepreneurial you
know he was always coming home with
something on the weekend saying I've got
this new product idea I've got this new
service I found and and you know our
basement was full of these different
attempts at different things and so
there was this this spirit of trying
things out by all means in our household
what were some of the things that your
dad tried on I know some early internet
things and the mid 90s as the internet
started to come out you know what were
some of the things that caught what did
he what did he end up doing well he
ended up working with my mom and they
both were in the health food industry so
when you go into Whole Foods and you see
you know vitamins and supplements in the
vitamin aisle they were the
representative between the manufacturer
of those products and getting into the
Shelf of those stores uh-huh what was
interesting was to tag along with with
them on business trips where they drive
around the South from South Carolina to
Tennessee to Alabama and getting to see
how they interacted with these store
owners because it wasn't just Whole
Foods it was the also the mom-and-pop
vitamin stores as well our independence
independence and so really fascinating
was watching them interact with the
store owners and it's just seeing how
far they would go to serve people you
know I remember one time specifically
we're in Tennessee and it was really
late at night all the other store
employees had gone home
it's my dad myself and the store manager
and we're sitting there stocking shelves
we're like so this is Tennessee yeah
we're doing somebody else's job but it
for my dad it was just about creating a
connection with with the store owner and
really I guess going above and beyond
what was required of you and so I really
took away from that those you know
observations of watching how your
parents treat people you know there's
just it was really nice to see
and it definitely planted a seed in me
of you know going out of your way for
those that you're serving
was it your was it your dad's idea to
bring you along did you ask to be
brought along or something else yeah I
remember the the very first morning in
the house that we rented yeah Florida we
had heard of date with destiny being
nicknamed by some people date with death
because the schedules so intense right
yeah 12:16 God knows how many hours it's
up to up to the powers that be the big
man and so on and it can be very hard to
get food maybe very hard to get a break
and even if you do get a break maybe
there's a line of 300 people from 60
countries waiting to get a chicken wrap
so you're not gonna get your chicken
wrap and so we had stocked up with bars
and mixed nuts and yogurt and jerky and
everything imaginable and it was
scattered all over the place and got up
in the morning and the entire collection
of food had been rearranged like a
point-of-sale display perfect it was
ready for a storefront and I was just
like did you do that to my two of my
friend AVI and he's like no I definitely
didn't do that I and then I knew Amelia
hadn't done it I was like dad knows I go
then Joe senior like be like some eggs
I'm happy I'm making some eggs would you
like some songs like Wow
oh yes it makes sense makes sense that
attention to detail okay you got a
little taste of oh it was great that I
was thrilled what else did you what else
did you experience in childhood that
stuck with you and I'll lead with one
thing that I originally asked you all
about and when we initially spent time
together also related to Tony Roth
that's Tony's the glue that holds us
together which I didn't expect to really
be verbalizing that it seems at least up
to this point that he's been a ace a
consistent character in the background
or in the foreground this is big dude
hard to miss but we began
my tennis because I just taken my first
ever tennis lessons with Jim lair and
Lorenzo Beltrami an incredible coach
down in Florida but you were wearing a
Nick Bollettieri or bullet Air Academy
shirt and I knew just enough having read
the open autobiography by Andre Agassi
to recognize the name so I asked you
about it so it seems like tennis was
certain certainly something that was
also oh my god one of the family so
maybe he could talk to that we had a
tennis family you could say I think
that's what they call that at a time
where every member of the family plays
tennis we did coaching together we
played in Ulta and USTA together we did
competitions together and it was a truly
a family sport growing up and so tennis
was a huge part of my life as a kid
amongst a lot of other sports
I think that's have things that stood
out to me as of childhood and things
that one of things I'm really grateful
for is that whatever my interests were
my parents would support it and I think
they learned this lesson the hard way
how so they they got me into violin when
I was really young when I was like about
4 or 5 years old which you were
interested or not interested my I mean
no and so I was taking violin lessons
and there's a recital that I don't
remember how old I was maybe six and at
this recital it's in Savannah Georgia
I'm starting at gusted Georgia and I'm
definitely out of my depth here like all
the kids are bigger than me I'm not
being able to keep up with everyone else
is playing and apparently I sat down on
the front of the stage and just put my
violin down and there's my parents in
the back probably the terrified look in
their face and after that experience
they switched their perspective and said
we're gonna support whatever his
intrinsic interests are right and so I
was really grateful for that you know
throughout my childhood sports
music and art were the three things that
anytime I threw my weight behind
something they were right there to
support me but it was of a you know
practice 'la sports practice or sports
equipment or music lessons or art
supplies whatever the thing was they
were there to to support me in it
what if not violin where did you
gravitate towards me in music is in the
violin lessons I do remember this this
part I was so eager to finish the vine
last violin lesson so that I could go
bang on the piano that was in the same
music room and sure enough I started
taking piano lessons and I've played
ever since cool so you still play I do
yeah I've got a piano at home and it's
like one of those things you know it's
the first thing I do when I go home at
the end of the day is I just got jam on
the piano I either play some of my
favorite music from colonial monk or do
you brew Beck or I just make stuff up
and kind of riff what other
entrepreneurial experiences do you
recall from elementary school or high
school after you got the kibosh thrown
on the teenage materials that sort of it
wasn't the end you know I I just think
we remember a whole bunch of things from
part of the common stuff right like I
started a long million business in my
neighborhood so I put her on fliers in
people's doors in my neighborhood and
offered 1 million car-washing and so you
know I'd go want ml 1 for 20 bucks
no that just was quick money in my
pocket as it as a kid kind of getting
into high school there was a one moment
where senior year came around and the
senior year t-shirt that it did my high
school it was it was pretty uninspiring
let's just call it that and I thought
you know I bet I could do something
better than that
at this point I just got my first Mac my
first Apple computer and I had photoshop
on it an illustrator and the graphic
software that you needed to to make you
know visuals and so that's when it was
actually when my introduction to
photoshop was I just redesigned the
t-shirt
and I didn't have any money really other
than the long line money that was coming
in and I figured out how to get these
t-shirts made I went to a local printer
figure out how to do all the transfer
the files to them and suddenly I'm
sitting on about 300 t-shirts and I
realize I gotta go sell these things
okay goddess you took it upon yourself
to redesign the was it the high school
t-shirt yeah like this the senior the
senior like the senior t-shirt the
senior t-shirt and then went out and now
you have a bunch of inventory I got a
bunch inventory I gotta sell them which
would come up again later another story
but yeah it was it was it was fun and
actually I remember I did better than
break even on those and people really
happy to have a really memorable what
the shirt you know it was a riff on the
the tide logo I'm gonna tie detergent
sure and so instead of st. Pat said
seniors class of 2000 broeckel in high
school and it did really well so you
didn't you didn't bet the farm and lose
the farm you you at least broke even
yeah yeah it was it was fun to learn you
know how to use some of the graphics
programs like Photoshop and then also
figure out like how do you turn that
into something right has it leave your
screen and become some physical so it
was a great lesson if anything where did
you think now this was senior year in
high school yeah what did you think you
were going to do when you grew up per se
at that point well or what did you want
to do so every year from elementary
middle and high school
the art teacher would tell me you need
to take more art classes because it was
a talent that I had that stood out and
they recognized that were telling me
about it and so you're every year I
would invest more into our classes and
at one point I was driving downtown to
the land a college of art and weekends
to take figure drawing classes sometimes
on weeknights I'd drive down for
painting classes and and then something
really incredible happened I applied for
this program called the governor's
Honors Program in high school where they
take students from around the state of
Georgia across all disciplines math and
science and languages and art
and they pick about 30 students about
the state for each discipline and then
if you get in you go to a college campus
for the summer and you actually study
college-level coursework in whatever the
discipline is so I went for art and I
had an incredible time here I was
surrounded by it some of the other you
know the best artists in the state of
Georgia and other high school students
and I had teachers who were collegiate
level challenging us the same way that
would a college student and I freaking
loved it and there was one woman in
particular name is Donna and she's like
one of those people in life that you
have along your journey who helped you
helps helps you see something else about
yourself that maybe you don't quite
realize yet and so she sat me down one
day during this program and and really
kind of laid out what it might look like
if I pursued art after after high school
and she was one of the first persons I
got me really excited about if she made
it realistic for me to even think about
it was that even a practical idea right
and she's like there's one school you
have to go to it's the Rhode Island
School of Design and I'm like the what
where's that and so Sutton the Bahamas
yeah she put RISD on the map for me and
I was turning up that program during
that that summer I really dope into
painting I did this painting that was
about eight feet by 4 feet wide
stretched my own canvas and really like
threw myself into understanding
materials and paint better than ever
ever before and we had the show at the
end of of the program so you know
everyone in art the discipline got to
have a gate like a gallery show and
there it was my painting on the main
wall when you walked in it was really
like it was a moment for me to realize
that people are appreciating the images
that I made in my art and seconds I
loved it like I really felt a challenge
I felt creative it was it was allowing
me to fulfill all these these desires
that I had to create things how much of
that was the environment versus the
medium do you think I think the probably
the environment a little more because
the medium could have been anything
right I mean we
raku pottery and firing we do figure
drawing painting we were exposed to all
kinds of different mediums and materials
I think the environment is what I fell
in love with the being challenged being
challenged being surrounded by other
creatives and and really that's what
triggered me to say how this Rhode
Island school design thing so the next
summer I did their high school program
and got to spend six weeks on campus
basically is like a really act like a
freshman right they give you again
college level courses and Ashley's due
at RISD I fell in love with the campus
fell in love with the people and you
know as a junior high school Mike I got
to go here this is this is where I feel
challenged so then then what happens
well so before I leave high school
there's a there's another story about
entrepreneurial jail so I haven't told
this story in a while but so when I got
to high school as a freshman the senior
class right before me had pulled off
this amazing senior prank so at our high
school the the mascot is a Bronco horse
so it's the Brookwood Broncos and they
went down the street to this like a
country-western store where you get
cowboy boots and cowboy hats
it's called horse town East and on the
top of their sign which was pretty tall
is a couple stories a couple stories
tall was this giant full-size plastic
horse and somehow the senior class
figured out how to get the horse down
from the sign and then they put it on
top of our school and so the last day of
class everyone came in there's giant
full-size plastic horse on top of
Brooklyn and so when I showed up as a
freshman everybody was talking about it
I every one's like yeah he shared with
the senior class did last year for the
graduated yeah and I just started to
think to myself I can I want to outdo
that I've got four years to think of
something like you but surely I can come
up with something better
and the horse on top of the school so I
set myself a challenge a prank by senior
year so the years go by it's now senior
year and we have about four months to go
and I still haven't thought of anything
and the clock's ticking it's now three
months to go I still haven't thought of
anything it's now two months to go and I
get onto Google I search you know high
school senior pranks just to see like
what else is out there because I'm still
committed to figuring something out and
so I keep coming across the same stuff
you've got super glue the locks the
doors you've got philip cups with water
in the gym put them all next to each
other it's they like knock over and then
you've got put three pigs out into the
school and label them 1 to 4 so everyone
thinks there's the third Pig run around
so you know it was like a repetition of
helmand and sites were covering these
pranks is like these are not original
right and that was one of my Cartier
like this needs to be something original
I'm not gonna just like copy another
prank and so we're now like three weeks
until graduation don't have any prank I
haven't figured it out yet and my sister
was a cheerleader and so she'd have this
shooting practice after school and
normally I'd have to hang around and
take her home and so I'm outside after
school one day and she's nowhere to be
found this is before cellphones and the
way that you tracked somebody down at
that time was to they make some
announcement over the intercom system
and think alike all their name so I go
into the front office and by the way I
went to the high school in Georgia that
was one of the largest we had over 4,000
people in a high school right since one
of the biggest high schools in the state
and I thought that to access the
intercom would be some you go in some
room there'd be some big system to be
super complicated so I'm in the front
office and I'm looking at the secretary
and I go hey I'm just trying to find my
sister Kim can you can you page her over
the intercom and the star he goes oh
sure just a minute
she picked she picks up the phone
and she hits pound zero zero on the
dialpad
and then she talks into the phone hey
Kim Kim Gabi Oh your brother's here
please come to the front of the building
and everything she said into the phone
came out over the intercom system and
I'm watching this and I'm going it's
that easy to get into the intercom
system of the largest High School in the
state of Georgia all you have to do is
have access to the phone line and hit
pound zero zero it was this big aha
moment as I'm watching this unfold in
front of me and I go all I have to do is
get one of those splitter jacks plug it
into the same phone line and then I can
run a cord of another phone somewhere
else in the closet or something and then
I could call in and have access to the
whole intercom system so for a week I'm
toiling on this I'm like how am I going
to route a phone cord without anybody
noticing it and then finally it dawns on
me just get a cordless phone you could
be anywhere in the school and have
access to the intercom so this point I
recruit one of my buddies Mark
Eisenhower who looking back probably
wasn't the best accomplishment for this
mission because he played on the
basketball team is about six foot four
with bright blond hair right can not
inconspicuous not it conspicuous at all
and so we go we go to the school that
weekend and we have this grand plan that
will well maybe trick one of the
janitors into letting us into the main
office and when he leaves somehow will
like plug in this cordless phone into
the school it definitely was not a well
thought out plan at this point but we'd
have a lot of time and so we hit we just
went for it and so we went to the school
was on my Sunday afternoon I think the
janitor saw right through us he did not
let us in the office and so we left a
bit empty-handed
but we weren't even up mm-hmm this was
too good so I employed another friend
name is Chelsea Hughes and so the three
of us came up with a better plan that
we'd go up on a week on a weekend
and there was a community school office
that we knew would be open on weekends
and that office connected like these
inner chambers to the main office and if
we could just get into that one we the
thought was you could go through the
sequence of other doors to get into the
main office and so Chelsea went up and
tried to figure out where that principal
was that that Community School Director
and so she she identified him on the far
side of campus she signaled to mark mark
signaled to me and I'm outside in like a
black hoodie with my backpack full the
phone a flashlight and Mark gave me the
signal hung mr. totally I go running in
through the lobby of the school right
into this community director's office
and then it's pitch black and I'm I'm
like going going through all the doors
that's like chamber by chamber until you
get to the main office the front desk
I'm gonna get them there and I moved the
desk to the side and there's just giant
jumble of chords underneath and I'm
trying to figure out which one what the
hell's the phone line and then I trace
it back to the wall I pull out the
splitter piece I put it in and then I
plug in the cordless phone and the phone
from the desk into the same line and I'm
trying to bury the cord base underneath
the pilot cords and in this point I'm
sweating my heart is racing I'm like I'm
within the darkness of this office
definitely not supposed to be there and
all of a sudden there's a tap in my
shoulder okay my heart jumps I turn
around its its mark hovering over me
goes Joey we gotta go mister choke is on
his way and I'm alright I'm done so we
pushed the desk back we go out the back
entrance into the parking lot we meet up
with Chelsea I pulled the cordless phone
out of my bag I turn it on and we get a
dial tone we have access to the intercom
so the next question is what do you do
with that access alright so the next day
I decided that I was gonna make a tape
mix of different songs deploy over the
intercom system and I play I put
together a mix of Pink Floyd we don't
need no education
and Alice Cooper school's out for summer
mm-hmm and I hadn't got so detailed
about this that I had my mom help out at
home she didn't know she was helping me
but we had two phone lines in the house
one for the business one for personal
use and I would call one phone line to
the other and have the tape player next
to it to figure out the right volume on
it the right distance from the phone and
have my mom on the other end telling me
if it was loud enough or not she helped
me calibrate the right the right volume
for the tape player so the the phone is
embedded the tape makes tape mixes is
made it's now the last day of school and
I woke up that morning I was nervous I'm
like I got to do this today all right
prank is happening so I go to school a
little bit late on purpose so as it
works I park I park my car in the
parking lot and in one pocket I've got
the phone the other pocket I've got this
tape player like a hand help like Sony
Walkman and I'm walking through the
parking lot it's just just me there's
nobody else and then all of a sudden our
school police officer shows up on his
golf cart and he turns the corner and
he's coming straight towards me and
there's nobody else around it's just him
and me and he's coming at me and I'm
staring at him and I'm like just be cool
just be cool he doesn't know and like
he's getting closer my heart's racing
faster and I'm like oh my god I've got
this the bulges in my pocket of the
phone and the tape player and he makes
eye contact I mean the golf cart goes by
so I walked to the front of the school
and there's like this overhang area
where the buses pulled up and there's
these benches and then the these glass
doors before you go into the main lobby
and so everything's cleared out except
for this one kid he must have been like
a freshman or a sophomore or something
and he's sitting there and I'm like
waiting for him to leave because I don't
want anybody see what I was about to do
and he's not going anywhere
and I'm thinking myself I have to do
this
like I can't wait any longer so I just
run up to him I get right in his face
and I go look you can't say anything
about what you're about to see and he
was just totally freaked out he goes
okay
and so I go behind one of these these
brick columns that was holding up the
overhang and around the column you could
see into the glass doors and and where
the offices were the phone bases so I
pull the phone out I pull out the tape
player my hands are shaking oh my gosh
stuff all right it's go time I turned
the phone on get the dial tone I hit
pound zero zero my hands are shaking
even more I take this deep breath and
actually this beep comes over the whole
school to signal there's an announcement
and I can actually hear myself breathing
so hit play in the tape player
I set the two down next to each other
and as I'm doing it I flick the volume
all the way just to be safe because I'm
thinking myself I don't want to come
across as too soft in the volume so I'm
like I got to throw the volume all the
way up so I set the two down next to
each other and I walk into the building
and that's when all hell broke loose I
opened the lobby I go into the lobby
doors and the music is blasting out of
the intercom system
school's out full so do you it's like
the speakers are about to explode it's
like so freaking loud and when you get
to school late you had to go to like a
check-in line to sign-in and so I'm in
the check-in line there's like two
people in front of me
and this is this is a scene I'm in this
like you know kind of high school lobby
to my left or all the offices including
the one where the phone is to my right
is a gymnasium Advan gymnasiums two of
my buddies come busting out while this
musics blasting they're laughing so hard
because they realize that it was me the
coach comes out of the gym starts
yelling I'm pretty you get back in here
we don't know what's going on but you
got to get back in here I'm just sitting
there with a straight face not cracking
a smile I sign in and then to get to my
class I have to walk past all these
offices right and so while I'm doing
that I hear what's going on
they're yelling at each other people are
sticking their head out of the office is
it coming from in there no I don't know
where it's coming from there I got the
phone in their hands you can hear all
the intercom
then hit like numbers on the phone
trying to shut it off they had no idea
where the heck it was coming from and so
as I'm walking past these sequence of
offices I catch a glimpse into the the
principal's secretary office and then
into the principal's office which is
even a deeper layer and I see I catch
her face and it's bright red and she's
yelling at somebody while this music
still playing right right now we're on
to Pink Floyd at this point you don't
need know so this has been going on this
is like three four minutes in at this
point yeah I'm walking through my
classes in the very back of the campus
I'm walking through the halls
I'm totally by myself while the music's
playing and every time I walk past a
classroom there's a little skinny like
glass window and you can kind of get a
glimpse into it and as I walk pass these
classes I take these double books and
people are like on top of their chairs
and on top of their desks and people are
dancing and I get to my classroom right
as the tape ends and look I thought for
sure they're gonna shut this off in like
20 seconds right so I didn't make a tape
very long it was a couple minutes I mean
a 20 minute taper probably played for 20
minutes right so I get there right as
the tape ends I open the door people are
staying on top of there - people are
dancing the teachers at her desk with
her head in her hands like totally lost
control of her class and it's like the
record stops I walk in everybody turns
and looks at me and goes Joey was at you
and I'm like no I don't know what that
was and so finally the teacher gets
control of the class again we sit down
and everyone's looking at me like Joe
that was awesome what was that
I don't know it's so not two minutes
later there's a knock on the door an
administrator walks in she walks over
the teacher the class goes dead silent
they whisper something to each other and
then they both turn and look at me the
administrator comes by my desk she goes
Joey get your stuff you're coming with
me
and I'm like sinking him and Destin like
oh no she gets outside she slams the
door we're in the hallway and she goes
you want to tell me what's happened to
back there I go I don't know we're
talking about she's like we've got mark
in the office we know what happened I'm
like I don't I don't know what you're
talking about she goes you can make this
hard you can make this easy on yourself
when I was like so we walk all the way
back to the front of the campus and the
whole way she's been training me chewing
my head off of all the damages that I
caused and all the issues that were
created with the phone system and we go
to the secretary's office and we walk
through and I see mark there he's got
his head in his hands and Mark is you're
very tall very tall very blond very
blond very obvious accomplice yes yes
he's a good buddy and a good friend and
I appreciate his help and so he's got
he's down like this he's like totally
crushed and he sees me and he looks at
me and he goes and I couldn't tell what
he was saying so he's just trying to
mouths words he's now something to me
and so he what are you saying he goes it
was the janitor so we get through the
secretary's office into the principal's
office Connie Corley I'll never forget
her name they slammed the door and I'm
standing with my backpack wearing a
green Izod shirt I'll never forget this
I'm in my brown khaki pants a green Izod
shirt with my backpack and there's
Connie Corley at her desk with her arms
like this kind of huffing and puffing
face is bright red she's got the phone
and the tape player and the phone cord
and the phone base on her desk and
around her are the 20 administrators
including the school police officer it's
the biggest school in the state of
Georgia we had our own police officer
and so they're all like this like arms
crossed huffin and puffin
right I'm like oh [ __ ] hearts racing I'm
like what is going on here every one of
them took a turn at me just to yell at
me about something
Connie coy starts yelling at me how did
you get in the office you broken a
Noreen and she's like like really angry
yeah I'm like oh like like I'm starting
to feel a little bit bad about this like
like I'm not sure where this is gonna go
like yeah is this am I gonna get off on
this or like oh there's some
consequences here I have no idea and so
from that they lead us into this other
like negotiation room which I've never
seen before it was this long wooden
table with these like leather chairs on
the whole side of principal Cory's at
the head of the table mark and I are now
sitting across from each other we've got
administrators standing nervous with
their arms crossed like we're gonna make
a run for it or something and she like
starts like negotiating with us and this
is the part that actually pissed me off
the most is that she started to threaten
our scholarships oh and she looked at
mark she goes mark you know I know
you've got a basketball scholarship to
this the School in Georgia that you're
going to I'd hate to have to call the
coach and tell him about this this
incident so it's me Joey I know you're
going to that art school in Rhode Island
I'd hate to have to call their
admissions office and tell them about
this incident and that was like there's
no way you're getting in the way of
either of our dreams right because we
tapped into the high school intercom
system like right so she didn't offer
she goes we could press charges for
breaking the entering and tampering
school property and some other things or
you can do this list of things which
included wiping down computer screens
and the library you know during the
summertime ironically setting up and
taking down the sound equipment for
graduation and like a few of the chores
in like manual labor
basically yeah and so mark and I
obviously we say well we'll do the
chores and the menial labor so that we
can graduate right pressing charges
somehow equated to not be able to
graduate get your diploma and so
from there we go into the the school
police officers office his name is
officer Harrelson and it's a good cop
name this guy yeah right this guy had
the deepest kind of grisly voice that
you could imagine office officer
Harrelson here Brooklyn high school so
we're in the office and he calls her
parents and this is this is like
probably were the worst part of the
whole story he did not know the update
that we opted in to do the women manual
labor
ah things that we're not graduating high
school now so he calls my mom because
Miss Gary this is an officer Harrelson
here at Brookwood high school yes ma'am
I've got your son in custody here yeah
yes right ma'am it doesn't look like
he's graduating this year
oh no yeah ma'am he's right here he
hands me the phone and I heard this tone
of voice in line for my mom I've never
heard since and everyone here again she
goes you could write home after school I
can't believe you click I'm like mom but
wait we're gonna graduate she thinks her
son's not graduating high school I'm
like thanks officer house and it was
really kind of you and does the same
thing to mark and we're walking out of
his office and this is the best part he
pulls us to decide he because mark Joey
I'm at the school for over 20 years and
you need to know that was the best damn
prank I've ever seen Harrelson so we go
through graduation one little funny
stunt Livi does that you know he had
your honors cords and different club
cords you wear around your neck mark and
I wore phone cords honor the senior
prank people were raving about it and we
came back you know two weeks later to do
white computer screens in the in the
library and I'll never forget we're
outside underneath the same overhang
like dusting off my rags and all these
buses pull up and all these bus drivers
start pouring into the school past it
has like some bus driver you know end of
your celebration or something and one of
the bus drivers actually walks over to
us and she goes
are you the two boys that pulled that
prank with the intercom system and mark
and I look at each other more like yeah
she goes you know y'all are you to her
are headings in this county Morgan I
like white like how did they hear about
it like all the bus drivers in the
county living with him so it was this
just incredible moment of you know
having an idea have this ambition to do
something that was original in this case
there was no property damage nobody got
hurt
just to me the essence of a great prank
and that was part one of the story part
one of the story
well alright I'll bite I'll bite what's
part two of the story it's a part to the
story I mean college this is about two
years later and one of my roommates
comes home one day and he says have you
heard that show it's on MTV it's called
high school stories pranks and
controversies and I got was about it's
like yes I just watching it's like they
showed this this some high school did
they had this high school's prank I was
like I sat up in my chair I go really
and tell me about that and he goes yeah
they film these guys who get this they
superglued the locks and the doors of
this high school and I'm like you have
to be kidding me the oldest trick in the
book and TVs making a show about high
school pranks and they're doing a super
glue in the lock prank I'm like I have
to get in touch with the producer I get
online and I track down the producer of
the show and I sent them an email that
was a teaser of the story but not the
full one and basically said if you want
to hear the rest of it here's my phone
number
about 30 minutes later my phone rings
for the two one two area codes NYC NYC
and I get on the phone with this
producer and he's like I'm really
intrigued by your email always looking
for good stories was it what he got and
I told him the breviary version what you
just heard and he's like oh I love this
I'm gonna pitch this to my executive
producer we're gonna get back to you
it's about three or four days later you
get another phone call from a two one
two
this is Leslie from MTV I'm the
executive producer here really loved
your story
want to hear more about it from you so
by the end of the call she's in love
with the story she's like you know what
we're gonna do we're gonna send a crew
down to Georgia we want you to come back
this summer we're gonna reenact the
whole thing and include it in the next
season of her TV shikko so that summer
we got to go back to Georgia and reenact
the whole thing now however this is only
two years later the same administration
and principal was still there all right
and they did not have a lot of
forgiveness I was gonna say the wounds
haven't healed over quite yet definitely
not healed they definitely had a grudge
because if anything we just embarrassed
them right they had no idea had to turn
it off like yeah there's no damage or
anything that was really that's
permanent and so they declined
reenacting at school so ironically went
to one of my rival high schools and
refilled the whole thing there and even
more ironic is that the principal the
new principal there was a former
administrator when I pulled the prank at
my other school so he was instantly
familiar what had happened at that point
he was he could laugh about it so that
summer we enacted the whole thing
Chelsea and Mark and got a couple of the
friends to be extras in the background
and it aired later that year on MTV
amazing so it seems like your brushes
with mischief just seemed to reinforce
your appetite for mischief of sorts in a
way perhaps now when we were hanging out
earlier today I asked a question that
that I often ask of friends I'm gonna
sit down with and it was in effect can
you give me any cues I don't want to
hear the story can you give them any
cues that might lead to a fun discussion
and and one of them I said I don't want
to know the story because I want to hear
it fresh and when we're recording and
one of them was NBA time worked with or
in NBA and I have no idea what this
refers to but that's cue
Tim I think this story starts by telling
you a fun fact I've seen Michael Jordan
naked in person okay
this is a good start now we're talking
about locker room hotel room barbecue my
job had a high school job where I worked
as a ball boy in the NBA for the Atlanta
Hawks that was my job in high school
okay I love basketball I played my whole
life and I was reading these I used to
read the newspaper every morning when I
was growing up over breakfast whatever
that I just consumed the newspaper and
so one day I'm in the sports section and
there's an article about a bat being bat
boys for the Atlanta Braves and being
ball boys for the Lana Hawks at the very
end of the article it said if you're
interested in becoming one send a letter
about yourself to this address and I'm
like oh my god yes like that would be so
cool right hmm so I send a letter but
actually I sent it on the day of the
deadline once it passed and I sent them
day the deadline and I kind of forgot
about it until the next summer I get a
phone call and this guy introduced
himself as Chris Tucker the strength
they had strength coach of the Lana
Hawks and he oh we got your letter we
really liked it we wanted you to come
down in an interview for one of my ball
ball boy positions I go this is awesome
all I'll be there
so we get onto at the time it was the
Omni before they had Philips Arena and
I'm interviewing with them you know tell
him about my life and my love for
basketball and these things and I get a
call back a few days later that I got
the job so this is I'm like a freshman
in high school right I'm like barely
like 16 maybe 15 15 years old and I
start working you know in the locker
rooms of Delana Hawks actually my very
first game I'll never forget this was
the Hawks versus the Toronto Raptors and
they threw me onto the the visitors
because their ball boys for
can you explain what a ball boy does in
basketball a because I'm an idiot when
it comes to group sports or team sports
I know that a ball boy or ball girl does
in tennis yeah but in basketball I have
no idea so bad there's different tiers
right the entry-level tier is you're
wiping the sweat on the floor when a
player falls down in the middle of the
game
all right right you've seen this yeah
like people go out with the mop and the
towel and you're just wiping the sweat
so the player doesn't slip on the court
mmm
it's like the entry-level position and
they did plenty of that as you work your
way up the tier then you work on the
side of the court and you'd actually run
and grab the players warm-up pants and
jacket when they went to check into the
game so you get half of like sitting on
half-court with them and you have a
towel
when they came in you know sit back down
on the bench and then the next here was
he'd worked behind the bench and
actually assist the trainer and so you'd
be handing the Gatorade over their
shoulder cool when I sit down give him
the towel get them their warm up their
their jacket of the hoodie and then the
highest-level was doing that for the
visiting team right and so and whatever
they needed to set up the locker room
before the game you'd run any errands
that need to get done you break the
locker room down at the end of the game
of the whole thing so you get through
the game like three hours early to do
all this you end up running errands for
the players sometimes you'd be like a
nice tip remember horse grant one time
gave me a hundred-dollar bill it's a big
deal he goes back to the bus it was
pretty cool and so they threw me my very
first game they threw me to the visitors
side Toronto Raptor just her afters and
it was my first experience right of like
being around some Amy greats Marcus
Camby I remember was on the team at the
time this guy watched play at UMass in
college and like really admired and it
was my first exposure to professional
sports locker room to it everybody comes
in and they just take the clothes off to
get a change and like nobody gives a
[ __ ] yeah it doesn't matter at the end
of the day but for me I was like whoa
whoa where am I Watson impression
topless as my first experience of course
you get used to that it's no big deal at
a certain point so I mean I'm in the NBA
and I did it for three seasons I got to
work alongside Lenny Wilkins the head
coach
Dikembe Mutombo
Smith some of these NBA greats and there
was some really incredible moments that
happen one of them one of them was when
the hot the Hawks played the Chicago
Bulls Jordans still playing this is 1999
one of his last seasons and I'll never
forget this so you have to imagine the
scene we're in Phillips Arena and the
Hawks are actually winning just amazing
and the place is going nuts
you can't even hear yourself think it's
so loud people are screaming there
they're playing music over the the
loudspeakers and I'm working the Bulls
bench right which is like you've got
Scottie Pippen Steve Kerr Dennis Rodman
Michael Jackson Phil Jackson Michael
Jordan like the whole roster yeah yeah
hell roster and some working the Bulls
bench third down Phil Jackson calls a
timeout and the place goes nuts because
the Hawks are up and in front of me
Jordan pops down Rodman's on the Left
Pippins on the right Phil Jackson it's
like right here and he's furious like
this guy's using expletives like you
never believe he's yelling things I feel
like I can feel his soul like his spit
like hitting my face he's just like and
I'm like right behind Jordan he's right
here and the place is against oh wow
people are screaming at the top of their
lungs and I'm doing my job right I give
the guy's a towel and then I'm giving
him a Gatorade so I'm like I'm gonna
start with Jordan obviously he's right
in front of me so I reach around
I reached on this side so left left hand
like over the shoulder left hand over
the shoulder Jordan is facing this way
talking to Pippen his right next to him
I reached around and Rodman who's to my
left turns quickly bumps my elbow the
Gatorade quickly goes upside down and
straight into Jordans lack there are
only a few times in life I've been as
terrified as that moment
Phil Jackson's yelling at me Michael
Jordan spins around he goes hey man
watch it I'm like oh my god like my
heart's rate like Jesus Christ so I did
what anybody would do in that moment if
you spill something you tend to wipe it
up right so I grabbed the towel and I'm
patting down Jordans thigh like now I'm
like in the huddle
right right Rodman is laughing at me
because he realized what he had done
Phil Jackson's like right here like
spitting he's yelling so hard and I'm
like I'm sorry Jordan I'm like trying to
like Dryas leg up with his Gatorade
spill that went right into his lap and
oh man I'm like sweating profusely
you're gonna get like the TV crews are
like in the huddle as a ball boy you had
one job don't pour the Gatorade on
Jordans balls well obviously
unfortunately Rodman made that quick
spin oh I'm gonna knock me not your
fault
so like the the buzzer goes off and it's
like time to get back on the court and
I'm still like patting down like
Jordan's leg and he's like oh come on
man and I think right after that he
actually had like a whole bunch of
points this way I'm dr. something I
think yeah the moralist story there is
uh you know when he still Gatorade on
Jordan make sure you clean it up what it
seems like there's another pattern here
which is getting comfortable with
uncomfortable situations right or
exposing yourself to discomfort yeah so
that you're comfortable sphere of action
expands right what what was your next
brush once you get to RISD so you're in
RISD were there any formative
entrepreneurial experiences that come to
mind absolutely we're
and I should explain also if I may
interject just for a second that one of
the reasons I wanted to explore a lot of
these stories is that it's easy and I
think typical for people to take a
single chapter in someone's life and
isolate it and view it as the whole
story right but there's so much
backstory and so much development and so
many experiences that lead up to the
small piece of the puzzle that people
tend to think is the whole puzzle right
right so just for people listening and
watching that's that's and I just enjoy
your storytelling so that's another
piece of it but the RISD yes this is
this is a level up I mean RISD you have
a lot of talented people at RISD any
entrepreneurial memories or experiments
that come to mind from RISD yes so I
decided to go to RISD to study Fine Arts
to be a painter and I don't really know
what that meant I had this vision of
maybe one day you know being able to
exhibit in New York or something like
the gallery scene I couldn't actually
picture it but really want to go study
art and painting so when I got to campus
they have this week of orientation and
you get your class schedule and you get
to meet upperclassmen and I'm so I'm
talking to this guy and fellow student
fellow fellow student upperclassmen and
he's saying oh who do you have for your
courses and freshman year they give you
the foundation stuff like drawing
two-dimensional design three-dimensional
design liberal arts art history and some
going through the list of teachers and I
say this one teacher's name that makes
his eyebrows go up I go I've got Gareth
Jones for 3d and he goes you got Gareth
Jones oh man I go what is it who's this
guy and he goes just wait for the chess
set project and I go what's the chess
set project and he goes you'll see so my
very first class is with this guy Gareth
Jones teaching three-dimensional design
and picture this we're in this art
studio with these concrete floors he's
like rickety metal stools
plasterer covered kind of work surfaces
it's a little bit cold it's September in
New England and you know it's a very
first class and I'm sitting around with
you know 18 other freshmen we're all
trying to make sense of where we are in
the world and what this RISD thing is
all about and this is about to be our
first impression of what does it like to
be a student at RISD and so we're
sitting there and all of a sudden this
guy were in all black with this big
poofy head of hair comes out and he
stands in front of us and he's got this
Welsh accent and he goes I just want you
all to know that half of you are going
to fail my course because you won't
finish the chess set project I don't
think yourself oh my god that's what
this is gonna be like here like half the
people left to my right one of them's
gonna be gone I'm gonna fail out I'm
like oh my god and we're all looking at
each other like is he serious
and he goes on to explain the chess set
project so in addition to your weekly
assignments the chess set project is
this semester long project that takes
place outside of the classroom on your
own time where you have to choose a
three-dimensional artist like a sculptor
like Henry Moore an architect like Frank
Lloyd Wright a furniture designer a
fashion designer and you had to find a
book about them and from that you had to
select pieces of their work to recreate
and you did it in the format of a chess
set which means it didn't have to look
like actual chess set pieces but you
take one of their creations and
replicated eight times for your pawn and
had to look exactly like the picture in
the book you took another one of their
creations and you had to replicate it
twice for the rooks in 3d in 3d and you
had to do it at 12-inch scale Oh God
I'm just looking at a picture you
definitive what's the backside look like
what's the underside look like and at
this time I had a growing interest in
furniture furniture design
I came across this furniture designer
from the 1920s and 30s named Gerrit
Rietveld he was a Dutch architect and
designer and he did these really
beautiful chairs that are actually in
the Museum of Modern Art there are
classics and I thought a couple of
things one is as I got to know Gareth
Jones the professor it became very clear
that this guy was super opinionated he
would argue to the death to make sure
that he was always right I would watch
him like just are you students like like
relentlessly
to make his point and out of that I just
had this growing thinking of like wow I
could I'd love to prove this guy wrong
at some point and so I also thought I'm
gonna throw myself into this project
there's no way I'm failing in fact I
want to I want to I want to complete
this project and if I'm gonna commit so
much my time to this and I'm gonna make
chairs from this designer Gerrit
Rietveld
at the end of it I want to come out with
something I can use
I don't want 12-inch chairs I actually
want full-size functional chairs and so
I'm like this is a really great idea
I'm gonna share this with Gareth so I
call him over and I'm like Gareth I want
to make full-size functional chairs and
my expectation at this time was that
he's gonna you know give me a high five
it's a Joe you can do it you got this I
believe in you instead to him he goes
Joe I really don't think you can do it
really focus on the smaller scale and he
walks away and I'm like no [ __ ] way
like alright buddy now you really have
to do it all right pal like you just lit
every fire that you need to light power
tools like the actual machine shop tools
and I was really stepping in unknown on
this and I had a semester to figure it
out so I just committed every all of my
time to making this project happen on
weekends Saturday nights my friends be
gone too you know parties on campus and
I was in the studio trying to figure how
to make chairs and so I I started by
going to the furniture department and
talking to upperclassmen and I actually
sat down with the the head of the
furniture department name is Rosanna
Summerson and I told her about my
ambitions and she looked to me kind of a
crazy face it's like you're never gonna
figure this out but she was encouraging
and she pointed me some upperclassmen
who then started help me understand wood
and machines and the tools the table
saws and band saws and lathes and the
things you need to make furniture and so
piece by piece I started to figure out
how to make these chairs
I was sourcing wood I had access to the
shop that they were giving me and the
thing is I never told Gareth where I was
in the project so every check-in he's
like how's Colleen I'm like it's alright
alright
and I would downplay my progress yeah
meanwhile in my dorm room it's starting
to fill up with these chairs everywhere
and so I like I worked my butt off and I
just I that whole semester I was like
hacking my way through it and I get to
the the pawn so I have to pick one of
his chairs and make it eight times he
made this beautiful bench out of just
four pieces of wood and I'm thinking
myself wow these benches are really big
that's a lot of wood I can't afford this
I'm just a freshman in college and so
I'm not you had to cover all your
material cost oh yeah okay no no that's
an important detail right so like a
study job at the time I was trying like
fun this however I could and so I'm in
the quad one day outside the freshman
dorms and I'm I make an observation
everyone's standing around smoking here
in the quad and there's actually nowhere
to sit huh I've got this bench design
that I'm gonna make what if I approach
the school get them to pay for the wood
I'll make the benches for my project
then they can have them afterwards to
put in the quad for people to sit on so
I go to the the head of residents life I
pitch him the idea he loves it
they fund a few thousand dollars worth
of this inch thick plywood and in doing
so I get access to the school's wood
shops and the school's craftsmen I could
work on campus and so now I've got their
help to help fabricate these these
benches
and they paid for all the wood which I
definitely never afforded and so by the
semester I've amassed 16 full-sized
functional chairs and Gareth had no clue
and actually finished the last chair at
about 2:00 in the morning the night
before the final [ __ ] the day before
the final crit crit created his critique
riot eek yeah a critique in art school
you have these critiques where you put
your art your work out and then the
professor in the class critique you and
that's how you learn how to improve as
an artist or designer and so it's like
now December it's freezing cold outside
it's Providence and I specifically chose
the slot right after lunch to present
because I figured when everyone's out
getting lunch
I'll get my roommates a couple buddies
to help me carry all these chairs and
assemble them in the space when people
come back there'll be this great reveal
moment because nobody has any clue
except a couple friends exactly what
I've pulled off here it's him my only
regret from this project is that I did
not have a camera in my hand I would
take a picture of Garrett's face he
entered the studio I swear I'm standing
there and he comes marching in and he
picks his head up and he looks at the
room suddenly and you can see him
counting in his head 15 16 and he looks
at me and he goes Joe you've done it
you've proved me wrong and we talked
about the project and I got very high
marks obviously and it was one of those
breakthrough moments where you have
somebody that you look up to tell you
you can't do something and you are
literally cast with something you've
never done before and somehow you
persevere through it you you ask for
help you you figure it out and and on
the other side of that I'm sitting there
in this chair sticking oh wow
like if I can figure this out what else
could I figure out yeah like this seems
like an impossible feat before this
whole thing started and Here I am I'm
sitting in these chairs the professor is
like beaming at me like and it was just
like one of these moments that one has
in life where you sort of cross the
threshold of understanding your limits
and at that point I had a new a new bar
or a new set of limits how did you feel
for from the point that he said that for
the rest of the day and what would what
did the rest of the day look like I mean
well first of all I was so tired I'd
been up for actually a head slept for
about three days before that so over 48
hours I was without sleep so I was
delirious hey bo was just so relieved
and then third I was like there's six
six excitement inside of me like I just
I just proved myself wrong
what else can I prove myself wrong on
and suddenly it's like there was so much
possibility of anything at this point
forward that I come across that feels
impossible I probably take a second look
at that mm-hmm and rethink that based on
this experience because again like how
do you make a chair and then how do you
make sixteen full-sized functional
chairs at the end of the project over a
course of a semester and so what's cool
is that the bench has got installed
students are sending them for they
lasted for a couple years after that and
so the legacy of it not only went to the
benches but the the story of what had
happened became his story that he told
every class after that so that's that's
really powerful on a bunch of levels
right because not only and I have to I
don't know the guy of course at all but
I have to give the professor credit for
being willing to say like you proved me
wrong right because also just in that
moment the power of that reinforcement
for you as a is a big deal I mean that's
a really big deal potentially
life-defining
inflection point of sorts secondly a few
things occur to me you created eight you
also created a a product an outcome that
people could
right versus a scale model and you
created a story that would then set the
bar infinitely higher not necessarily
the pass/fail mark but the you can
[ __ ] do this mark for students for
generations to come right many many
classes to come that's a big deal I've
said a big deal a lot because I think
you're a big deal Joe ah it's true and
one question that occurred to me while I
was listening to this was related to the
moment when he said that you couldn't do
it or he thought you couldn't do it and
how you responded to that it made me
think of a story that I heard from
Alexis Ohanian co-founder of Reddit when
they went in early some relatively early
and the development have rented to meet
with Yahoo and they were showing traffic
numbers and analytics to this Yahoo exec
and the Yahoo exec made this comment
which probably to him or her at the time
didn't seem like a big deal but they
said oh well this is a rounding error
for us and to my recollection Alexis and
his team went back to the office and
they put you are a rounding error up on
the wall to motivate the team but not
everybody responds to what you could
view as a deathblow that way so where
did you get that from I mean is that for
sports is it from your parents is it
from somewhere else is it just your
programming where do you think that
comes from there's just one source I
think sports is definitely a way to if I
had to point to something
yeah played somebody sports growing up
from tennis to baseball to basketball
the track and field the cross-country
like some of those are team sports some
of those are individual sports and in
all of those I mean in any sport that's
competitive you're trying to ultimately
compete with yourself to do a better
performance than you did the last time
right and so I looked at sports as this
constant
I was I was in a game with myself and
like cross-country was a great example
that sport like for me was I feel like
where I honed my goal-setting and was
able to practice pushing my limits so
every race I would if I crossed the
finish line and I could still really
like walk and had energy to me that was
energy I could use on the course to run
a faster race and so I finished I got to
this point where I literally would
collapse after the finish line and it
became so well known that like the
medics would be waiting for me that have
the ice bags and like they'd have like
the IV just in case and like the parents
would be there to like pick me up and in
the last you know 800 meters to the
finish line I'd always try to find
somebody who was running a little bit
faster than me and I just would try to
accelerate to catch up with them draft
them a little bit and then sometimes I'd
be neck-and-neck with them it's like in
the finish line see within sight it's so
close and I would just say out loud to
them I'd say you're not beating me
you're not beating me and I'd I'd use
that to motivate myself just to try to
run faster to get a better time that's
amazing this is their I'm glad you
brought up the sports because part of
the reason I asked is that it be and
it's a slightly different lesson maybe
or but one lesson that I took from
sports I went to two different high
schools the second high school I went to
had mandatory sports which I thought was
really in retrospect important for a lot
of kids and by being forced to do
various sports primarily wrestling in my
case if you want to get better you're
going to train with people who are
better than you yeah by definition you
are going to be beaten by other people
and at least in my experience I started
to view any type of failure in that
capacity being beaten as feedback right
I mean you're it's like a crit right
it's a it's a it's a it's a sports based
crit and that's why often times you know
when
and if you have a good coach they're
also going to be pushing you beyond what
your perceived limits are representing
and so you get into the habit
perhaps subconscious or otherwise of
asking is this impossible really
impossible mm-hmm because I never
thought I would break whatever
six-minute mile and I just did that and
then I never thought it's gonna break
530 mile and my coach just helped me to
do that or I figure that this hack which
is chasing the fastest person in front
of me and saying you're not gonna beat
me you're not gonna beat me and then I
collapse in a big mess of a heap at the
end but nonetheless hey I just beat 5:30
exactly or whatever it is and you feel
like you've you've expanded like you've
you've pushed the limits of what you
thought was possible within ralph and
that that for me was like one of the
greatest feelings yeah that I had at
that end it what strikes me is that for
me I didn't have many vehicles for
expanding that capability that was that
was as tangible as sports but design is
super tangible right I mean you're
building these chairs and these benches
and I should also just mention as a side
note that I want to I want to come back
to RISD that I don't think it's ever too
late people might be listening saying
well hey I didn't have a great
cross-country team or wrestling coach in
high school so kind of options creeks
like no actually you can still develop
that right with physical training and
and other outlets to expand your
capabilities and your perception of
what's possible sure and it's so funny
because that was a piece of advice I got
in seventh grade when I started playing
basketball the basketball coach said Joe
if Joe if you want to get better at
basketball you need to play with people
who were better than you yeah and so
when I used to go to the to the widest
shoot hoops in the weekend I wouldn't
play with people my age younger to
actually play with the high schoolers
who were much bigger much stronger much
more talented than I was and of course I
got you know pushed around and I like
you know you get bumped around by guys
who were you know playing on the varsity
team but man my skills the learning
curve that year I feel like that was
that was like a another kind of
threshold moment of like I'm not very
good at basketball too actually okay
I've got some skills now
and so I think since that since that
moment I've always thought to try to
find people to play with who'd better
than me and it'll certainly come up back
up when we talk about Airbnb so the so
the Welshman yes concedes defeat to the
space gasps Jones I by the way I am I
caught up for him with him I caught up
with him for a coffee about 12 years
later and I had to ask him I'm like here
was my experience of that conversation
like what the hell were you thinking why
didn't you get behind me he goes Joe
come on I knew that if I told you you
can do it you would oh oh yeah good man
we have a great relationship tonight I
see I'm gonna go back to campus that's
very cool
so so phase-shift you have that
experience you have that experience and
there's a great segue of sports into my
RISD experience I will have basketball
as we've been talking about and I walk
into the office of student life one day
and I go to the guy at the front desk I
say I want to play on the basketball
team and he gives me this funny face and
he goes we don't have a basketball team
and all of a sudden there's this like
this awkward silence I was just staring
at each other and he breaks the silence
by saying you can start one if you want
to hang out really what's involved in
that he goes well if you collect a list
of 12 other students and want to play
bring it back to me I'm like that's it
and I'm like okay so I've run off and
they spend a week but pretty post up
posters up around the dorms and I gather
names of you know 11 other people play
basketball wasn't actually that hard and
I come back to them like okay cool now
what you guys okay fill out this form
take this to the student government
meeting on Wednesday to get recognized
as a student organization I'm like okay
so I go to the meeting I present the
concept might have a basketball team
here's the paperwork here's the names
here's like what we think we might need
for a budget it gets proved it's from
the student government so then I'm like
I go back to Mike what's the next step
he's like okay well you need to find a
gym and
it's so nice one thing led to the other
and that year we we started rezzie's for
a basketball team in 40 years and we
started this this team it was like a
hodgepodge group of other students and
we would rent gym space at a private
high school in Providence to go practice
in and at this point were just
practicing like we would have the
there's no season there's no games
there's no competition it's just us
scrimmaging each other and we made some
really basic uniforms and just got
things off the ground the next year when
I came back to campus was was different
than like okay this year we're gonna
make a season we're gonna play other
teams like let's turn this into
something and so I get on the phone I
start calling colleges in New England
I'm calling community colleges and you
know University schools and I get on the
phone with some of these coaches and I
introduce myself hey this is Joe Gebbia
calling from the Rhode Island School
basketball team and I'd like to hello
hello pretty much everybody hung up on
that first couple phone calls but then
there was one college that took my call
I'll never forget it as I had to sneak
out of my graphic design class to take
the call it was Clark University in
Massachusetts I'm on the phone with
their head coach he's like yeah okay
cool we're not gonna send down our
varsity team but I'll send my JV team
and I'm like perfect we'll take it so on
December 4th 2001 we had the first RISD
basketball game RISD versus Clark
University and at this point like it's
so informal for us we've got these basic
mesh jerseys that are like reversible
basically have practice uniform for
anybody else and I'm player coach
leading the team at this point and we're
in not even our own gym because gonna
have one we're in some private high
school gym around the corner and the
Clark University bus pulls up and their
players start to get off the bus and I'm
going oh my god your shortest guy is
taller than our thought was guy
and they get the head coach three
assistant coaches and a trainer comes
off you know it's just like 12 scrappy
art school students on the court with
like basic mesh practice jerseys and I
think once the coach came down the court
he kind of recognized what he got
himself into any like oh boy
and so we had a few I think about
hundred fifty fans
yeah RISD students show up that first
game I say we got blown out it was 94 to
49 but in my mind that was a huge win
because we established something like we
got a team established and off the
ground to real milestone at RISD yeah
and it was an incredible experience the
next couple of years because it was like
running a start-up you know you had to
put a team together you had to raise
funding you had to create a brand you
had to market that brand yet to get
people in with the games and one of the
things I was most proud of is that at
RISD the work the work loads are
incredibly difficult and once you get
into your majors they you know they say
like sometimes you never see anybody
again because they're just so focused on
on the workload and other than
graduation the basketball games became
the only the time really during the year
where you'd have the full cross-section
of campus under the same roof at the
same time students faculty
administration professors alumni people
from Brown who were just curious and
want to come over and see what this
crazy RISD basketball team was doing and
so is this really cool moment where you
just bring people together and that was
I think really the the undertones
undercurrents of what the team is really
about sure it was about sport and
competition and staying in shape and the
camaraderie of being on the team second
that was also about bringing people
together automatically makes sense for
time traveling looking forward yeah so
it was a great experience I think a lot
of people asked what the name of the
team is and you know because we're an
art school we didn't have to have
traditional names you know
Brizzy and any arts school is all about
self-expression and and not holding back
and so there was a legacy of names on
campus that all had a particular theme
to them
and so the hockey team on campus is
called the nads so when you cheer it's
go gonads yes and so when we started the
basketball team we had to sort of fall
in line of the theme so the teams called
the balls and both the nads and the
balls are supported by the jock straps
which is the cheerleading team and
there's a whole theme I probably maybe
won't go into it here but there's like a
whole theme of sports at RISD that adds
to the I think the levity in the humor
of it are they all testicle related
there was a there was a I think there
was a rowing team at one point called
the the shafts lacrosse team I think was
cause you have some side note side note
mix I'm well caffeinated do you know
where the the word avocado comes from I
don't I'll tell you it comes from I
believe it's I want to say an older
Mayan language but someone can correct
me on the Internet I'm sure they will
comes from a word a hawk offal TLT and
I'll cuddle and avocado grow on trees
hanging one lower than the other and
pears and that means testicles so if you
want to make a RISD current RISD
students who might want to start another
team you could go with the avocados but
it requires a bit of explanation
well that sport be the most boring
juggling team and intramural juggling
remedial juggling teams so I have to ask
because I've been wanting to debut this
question for a while we talked about
crit I've talked about balls which i
think is a it's a bit of a reach but we
can segue to buns
when does crit buns enter the picture
here all right so it's freshman year at
RISD I'm in a drawing class and the way
it works again is like you'd come in and
it'd be an eight-hour class so in the
morning you'd pin your work up on the
wall you're drawing assignment from the
week
for and would we spend all day
critiquing it we're having to crit and
you know people would ask afterwards
how'd your crit go um am i crit was so
hard my teacher was so rough on me or
like he didn't go well or it was great
and about four hours in your picture
that the environment you're in an art
studio hardwood floors metal stools
wooden benches for hours and I'm sitting
on these hard uncomfortable surfaces
your butt starts to feel it and
everyone's wiggling around trying to get
comfortable so by the end of the day
you're incredibly sore and I watched as
my classmates exited the art studio with
this bun print on the seat of their
pants because all the charcoal dust pain
in ink that's on these studio surfaces
rubbed off onto her pants and sure
enough I look on mine my pants are
ruined too
so walking back to my dorm room I'm
thinking there's got to be a better way
if we're gonna endure these crits for
the next four years what if you had a
seat cushion that you could sit on to
make you comfortable and to keep you
clean and so I got back to my dorm room
and I pulled out my sketchbook and I
drew that same one print shape on the
seat of our pants and gave it some
dimension and I called it crit buns and
you know at this point I had no idea how
to make a product it's just your first
year at design school so I took the
sketch away now fast-forward to five
years later I've now done a dual degree
in graphic design and industrial design
and at this point I know how to make a
prototype I know how to translate
something from a sketch book into you
know a real working prototype and so I
make creep buns out of hard foam you can
actually sculpt it out of this special
foam and now I have this full-size hard
you know representation of the shape
which is like you know two buns that
come together and there's a handle so
it's for portability I take that hard
model I casted it in rubber and then I
pour into the cast a expanding
polyurethane foam so when I took the lid
off there was looking back at me the
first soft Crippen's
seat cushion
and it was great because now I could
walk around on my classmates I could say
hey what do you guys think how much did
you pay for this what kind of colors
would you want and people of course had
a cracked a smile when they saw it and
they had a good laugh but I really hit a
wall because I had a one-off prototype
but I didn't know how to get it to the
next stage and I certainly didn't have
the money or the funds to do that on my
own it was around this time my senior
year where I noticed a poster on campus
that says competition for the design
diploma submit your ideas here and at
RISD they give you your you know degree
and paper to degree and they also give
the graduating class at different object
every year so I submit coupons for the
competition and it wins it gets selected
to be given out to every graduate from
the RISD class of 2005 which is like
freakin incredible however they tell me
this on May 1st
graduation is on June 1st that's not
allowing that I have to deliver two
thesis projects for graphic design and
industrial design okay definitely don't
have time to take on anything else how
many students are on the graduating
class it's about 600 600 so I'm I'm like
I'm so exuberant and excited that like
oh my god they'll pay for the the the
manufacturing of a couple hundred
cushions at the same time I'm like how
the hell am I gonna get this done like
there is absolutely no time and so I
start I get on to Google and I research
phone manufacturers Tim I called every
single search result for the first 15
pages
I was calling people in India was
calling people in England I was called
people in Texas I was calling people in
California and everybody's had the same
thing well son you know it's gonna take
you about six weeks just to make the
metal mold in about another four weeks
for production sorry
click and I just went through everybody
was getting no no no no so then I went
to my professors in industrial design
and they also said that's never gonna
happen in time now at this point the
school is getting a little nervous
because the clock is ticking here
and they call me and they say how's the
project coming and like it's cool don't
worry and they go so is it gonna happen
I'm like probably and they go well you
have until Friday at five o'clock
to tell us if it's a go or nuttin so I'm
like okay and what is the sound of
Monday on a Tuesday something says like
Monday all right so fast-forward it's
four o'clock on Friday afternoon I have
no options everybody's telling me no
it's never gonna happen it's impossible
to manufacture didn't take many many
weeks if not months
and I'm like I don't have that many
weeks we've got three now and so I go
outside the industrial design building
it's like a sunny afternoon and I'ma
laying on the grass right on the river
in Providence and I feel the breeze on
my face the sound of the birds and I'm
looking up at the sky and I'm cleaning
myself I have to figure this out
I can't I'm not gonna give up on this
what haven't I thought of yet and I
realized that the guy that runs the
metal shop in the industrial design
building this guy's Steve I haven't
talked to him yet so I run back in the
industrial design building I go Steve
here's what's going on and he goes I've
got this friend Sam up in Cumberland
Rhode Island he's got a tool shop why'd
she give him a call maybe he'll help you
up so I get on the phone with this guy
see him and I just pour it out to him
I'm like Sam this is what I want to do I
give him every ounce of enthusiasm that
I have and at the end he goes oh you
really want this don't you but like yes
whatever you can do and he goes all
right here's what I'll do I'll move a
couple projects around if you send me
the 3d CAD file today I can make the
tool this weekend and send it wherever
you mean you send it on Monday and I'm
like oh my god I'm gonna call you right
back
because I remembered there is a pool
float company that I spoke to the week
before in Connecticut who pool floats so
it's like they make mud water wings or
whatever you would lay in and your foot
noodles and the things that float in
water made out of foam and the guy told
me he said well I remembered something
he goes you know we can't make the mold
in time but if you find somebody else we
can produce the cushion and the other
thing is it had to have a silkscreen on
the top that said RISD 2005 on it
and so I call back this guy Christophe
at like 4:50 p.m. right on a Friday he
should have been gone like I don't know
how I caught him still in the office and
I got Chris off its show at RISD
I got found somebody to make the mold
he'll have it to you by Monday can we
make it work
and he goes you really want this don't
you
you guys all right here's yeah just send
it to so I literally call the school
back might as well been five o'clock and
I'm like we got it here's where to send
the purchase order uh two weeks later
the day before graduation
six hundred [ __ ] bones showed up on
campus with a silk-screening on top that
said RISD class of 2005 the day before
it was impossible how do you make 600
[ __ ] bones 300 red 300 blue with a
silkscreen on top in such a short amount
of time when everybody's telling you
know like everybody just stared at me I
was like this is never gonna happen I
was exhausted it happened however it was
so fun to see my classmates running
around with [ __ ] buns
everybody had a pair and like it was
really fulfilling and it was worth all
the effort and all the energy and I
finished my two thesis successfully on
time and I got to graduate and
everything and while a lot of my
classmates went off to great jobs at
Summit NASA doing industrial design and
some of it some of the big design firms
like I do and others I made a decision I
said you know Rizzy and just Design
School in general this is such an
exceptional job of helping you come up
with a creative process to you know
think of really original creative ideas
they're the usually hit a wall though
which is that you stop it at the
prototype and then you move on to the
next project and for me it built up this
incredible desire to figure out how to
how did how do you get to the Shelf of
the store like how does your idea to
transition from that one-off prototype
all the way to the Shelf of the store
and so I thought well I want it I want
to decode this black
box I have to figure this out so I made
a decision that I was gonna use [ __ ]
buns to help figure out how you get a
product from an idea in your head to a
sketchbook at the Shelf of the storm so
the day after graduation I started my
first company to make and sell crude
buns and the beauty of it is that I
didn't get paid for the graduation
project but they gave me the metal mold
afterward which is a few thousand
dollars so with the biggest expense out
of the way I was off off to run so what
happened what happened to Krypton why
are you making [ __ ] buns today so that
summer I started to develop the brand I
bought patent which is design patent on
it filed the trademark and everything
and I went back to the school that
summer and I said you know that was so
fun for the graduating class what if we
did this for the incoming class as a
welcome to RISD gift and they loved the
idea and they placed my first order and
so on top of that order I attacked on my
own inventory so I did this production
run of I think a thousand cushions right
and two things happened the first is
that there were now 400 students running
around campus with [ __ ] buttons actually
using them in the studios I had to go
talk to them I could take photos of them
I could actually start to build stories
and narratives around how they use the
product and second thing that happens is
I'll never forget in my apartment in
Providence in the basement of like this
really old kind of early 1900s apartment
I had about ten boxes of hundreds of
[ __ ] buns like filled up this entire
room and I'm sitting there staring at
that I'm thinking oh boy nobody's coming
to my basement to buy these things I
have to go out into the world and Alize
how do I sell these things so I put
together a sale sheet and and I put on
my best shirt and my best shoes and like
just the best kind of like professional
look that I could have and the first
star I walked into was the Brown
University Bookstore and I asked for the
store manager and we sit down this
little conference room
and I start to go through my schpeel I
put the sale sheet in front of her a
sample cushion and I'm going through the
whole thing in a mic you know given all
my enthusiasm
and about 30 or so seconds in she looks
and she goes no thanks and gets up and
leaves the room and I'm just sitting
there in this tiny little
fluorescent-lit conference room by
myself with my cushion of my sail sheet
and no sail like actually a pretty
horrible rejection so I walk back to my
apartment very slow walking like a
Charlie Brown Snoopy kind of walk and
and I'm seeing myself
that sucked I'm like how the hell am I
gonna sell these cushions if that's the
reaction I mean again and I was in that
moment where I remembered this sales
equation that I had heard at this
entrepreneur weekend at Brown University
that I snuck into one time and the guys
talking gave this equation for whenever
you introduce a new idea into the world
it was an equation for receiving
rejection and how to move past rejection
and the equation was SW squared plus WC
equals M oh wow hell of a memory yeah
I'll get my self zero seconds already
forgot it all right one more time
SW square SW squared plus wcwc equals M
oh all right so SW squared is some will
love your idea some won't
uh-huh Plus who cares equals move on so
I'm telling myself okay has to be square
who cares I just got to move on and so I
did I'm like all right I'm just gonna
find another story some people are gonna
love it some people aren't it doesn't
matter I just got to keep going I can't
get hung up and one person saying no I
need to go keep going so I find can find
somebody that says yes so I went to the
next door they said done went to the
third story
they also said no I went to the fourth
store which was this little tiny gift
boutique store on Thayer Street in
Providence sign up there yes had a
Halloween out there to help Halloween it
is that's a crazy street of uniformly
so I go into the store I give him the
pitch the sale Street at this point I'm
tweaking everything I'm iterating as I
go and the woman goes I'd love to bike
I'd love to buy some cushions from you
I don't like oh my god she goes I'd love
to buy four I'm like thinking inside oh
yeah she could've bought one and I would
have been happy so she starts to go to
the thing well here's you can ship them
too and here's the address and I go oh
no I'll go pack them up at my house and
bring them back to you today she's like
really I'm like yeah I packed up my cash
I was so excited I gave them serum I
went back later that night after they
closed it's like it's dark on Thayer
Street I go to the front of the store
and I press my face up against this cold
glass and I can kind of see my my breath
in the glass and there's a dim light on
in the back of the particular they're
closed and I'm scanning the store and
I'm squinting and there it is
I can see kripp buns on the shelf of the
store yes like I did it yeah like
everything after that point was downhill
like I it was like I knew how to walk
into the store and you gotta talk to him
downhill downhill is in a good sense I
keep pushing the boulder downhill right
right before I was like trying to climb
uphill against all these obstacles now
it was just like coasting downhill now
was that because you had the skills or
because you did proven to yourself that
you could do it heard it myself I could
do it is that like one proof point for
cushions for cushions on the Shelf of
the store I'm like hallelujah somehow it
happened now I have to like even more
confidence to walk into a store meet
with a buyer and ask the question now
what's the process to get a new product
into your store and I could sit down
with them and talk about the product how
it was so I make trips to Boston and
talk to stores there I go down in New
York I talked to frat
I talked to school visual arts talked to
Parsons
[Music]
I talked to more stores in Providence
what was the furthest away you traveled
to sell crap once I go home to Atlanta
for the holidays
it's all that stores in Atlanta I mean
everywhere I went I was always carrying
a cushion with me
I talked to anybody about it right it
was like everybody I talked to I was
just practicing the
[ __ ] and just is to get comfortable
with it so at that product and that
concept just you know it was never meant
to be anything huge it was just meant to
be grad school in essence to help teach
me like the whole stack of product
development because I was doing
everything out of my apartment from the
distribution the packaging the
fulfillment the website the press like
everything was run from my desktop
computer next to my bed in my bedroom
and so I got like in a very Mike like
you know a very small scale I get the
full you know ecosystem of what it means
to run something obviously at a very
small manageable scale which is perfect
and so one of the one of the defining
moments was I set a goal for myself I
said what's the store shelf that would
be the pinnacle for me like what I just
be the most proud of and one of the most
heralded shelves for any designer to get
on is a shelf at the design store at the
Museum of Modern Art oh yeah New York
City huge huge I mean there's legends
are there like you can get even stuff
you can get George Nelson stuff you can
get like the greats of the greats right
along with modern things of course and
so I set my goal I'm like I'm gonna
figure out how to get crit buns into the
moments tour and after two years of just
not giving up I finally got my first
order from MoMA I will never forget that
phone call okay now you are clearly
gifted or you've developed and
cultivated gifts with art and design
you've also had a lot of practice
pitching right through good and bad
experiencing rejection and acceptance so
what what got you the acceptance and
what was what was the like what was that
what was the pitch what was the process
at a certain point I think they realized
I wasn't gonna go away I'm like alright
this is just easier to like this guy he
knows I never asked them but the product
and I'm selling out of their store did
you sell people did you send people
there to buy them I remember going I
definitely made a trip down in New York
first shipped him the order and I walked
in and there it was in the shelf at the
moment I took a picture and I just
thought like wow like this seemed if you
if you if I had told myself three years
earlier that I would have made a product
that would be on the Shelf of them on
the store I would have said you're crazy
like that's impossible
so what gave you the foot spa to pursue
it for two years and was it the fact
that you'd I think it was there so many
Impossibles that you'd proven possible
to yourself was it something else
it was just wanting to experience it
that feeling like what I imagined it
might feel like if I were to ever
accomplish something that was so such a
stretch goal for me I don't know like I
just the dough balls relationship with
the buyer at the time and I think that
just evolved into an order eventually in
you know at that point like wow what was
next right so was that now I'm gonna
prompt one thing because it just popped
into my head was MoMA before or after I
want to say trade show in Japan it was
before it's before yes we can't I only
remember bits and pieces of this but can
you describe yes Pam so the product
ended up taking me around the world and
this was still for colleges well no I
mean this is for any kind of you know
gift Fair or any kind of event where
those other designers selling their
things so I got connected with this
website called design boom com one of
the biggest design blogs in the world
and they had this thing called the gift
the gift Mart and they basically would
invite designers from around the world
to come sell their things at these big
Design Week events where it would be
really hard to afford access to it as an
independent you know young designer they
would kind of create that opportunity
for you pay for the booth exactly they
have the entire spend a small fee to pay
but nothing like the actual cost and so
they subsidized it to make it possible
and so I got involved in that and it
took me all over the place i traveled
sydney australia where I sold the
cushion
I traveled to New York and I traveled to
Tokyo for design week one year and this
was fascinating because I got to
experience what it was like to sell the
cushion in person to directly to
consumers it's one thing to sell to a
store manager than it is to sell to the
actual customer very different the other
thing was RISD has these events where
the alumni can come together and sell
their creations with the ceramics or
furniture products and so at this point
I had figured out after hundreds of
interactions with people face to face
you know I designed my stand with the
cushions and a big signs that crib buns
you know supporting creativity where
others can't and I actually have seen it
so many times at this point I was able
to break the sales process down into
five steps there were five stages to the
crippling sales process the first stage
is what I call the what the hell is that
stage where people are walking by and
they do this double take and they look
at it and they're like what is that but
the shape and the color is interesting
enough to draw them in and so then they
get the stage to which is called the
touch and fuel phase they grab the
product off the stand they squeeze it
they realize it's soft the first smile
this is also my sanding process by the
way please continue they they kind of
got a smile on their face and they flip
it over right and they enter stage 3
which is the story phase so on the back
of the package I tell the story you know
in a couple of lines you know how the
product was concepted how I was created
who made it and you see them reading the
story and then they smile and they make
the connection of why the thing is the
way it is then there's stage 4 step
number four is tried-and-true I've seen
this everywhere they immediately start
going like this with the cushion they're
here they're looking around because they
want to try it out does it deliver what
it says it's gonna do does it make any
hard surface more comfortable so I
always have a demo chair nearby for
people to try it out
and so people sit down on it and as
they're sitting on it I had a chair next
to them and I'd I'd lean over to them
and I figured out the question to ask I
asked somebody how do you see this
fitting into your life and what's
amazing is that people told me all kinds
of different uses that I never even
imagined for the cushion there's
actually 35 different uses for it people
use it for camping trips people take it
to baseball games soccer moms love it
for their kids
pregnant women love it because it takes
the pressure off your tailbone when you
sit down because it's got a dip in the
middle people with Sky attica love it
because again the dip in the middle
takes pressure for tailbone I won so
many uses for the thing just by asking
people that question and the minute that
people could connect it to something
that's important in their life there's a
very high percentage that they bought it
and in 1999 it like it wasn't you know a
huge commitment bank breaker
so that was stage 4 stage 5 I never
could have predicted and this was really
the magic of learning what it's not only
about a product but it's about a story
as well I would literally watch people
buy my product they'd stand up they
turned to the next person in line he'd
say what the hell is that
and the person who just bought it would
literally tell them verbatim the story
about in the back of the package they
would sell the product for me I would
just sit back and watch this happen and
I'm like this is amazing and I realized
the power of story in that moment that
design is more than just a product it's
more than just you know digital
experience it's that cushion is 50% foam
and 50% story it was a really valuable
lesson and so I used a guy learned from
that every time that I went to these
different events so here we are in Japan
we're in Tokyo and it's really exciting
my first time to Japan I'm like thrilled
I'm like my senses are just like
overwhelmed with everything about Tokyo
and I'm at this five-day design event
for design week this is back in like
2008 2007
and so I go out there with 40 cushions
which are these two giant boxes like
these they take up a lot of volume right
and I'm like I take this things on the
plane and then I take them through the
Tokyo subway system like it's really
awkward cuz you can't carry you have to
like drag them and it's like I'm like
this you know for those people who
haven't been Tokyo every once in a while
you'll encounter a subway car that has
lots of space that is not the default
particularly if you're going during any
busy period there are in fact certain
stations where they have attendants
wearing white gloves will push people
into the cars so that the doors can
close and it's sardines in a can so I'm
just imagining you dragging these things
imagine I've got my big backpackers
backpack I've got these two giant
cardboard boxes of 20 [ __ ] buns each
that are like heavy and awkward I'm
trying to navigate the narrow subway
system of Tokyo and I get to my setup at
the at the design fair and I've got this
little tiny folding table to my left and
riding all around me or other designers
as part of design boom and I'm so
excited as people come walking up on day
one I start talking to them to try the
telling the story and nobody speaks
English and by the end of day one I sold
a total of zero [ __ ] buns and the king
himself oh my god this is this is not
good I'm definitely not going home with
40 cushions I need to change my strategy
here because this is not gonna work the
story is not translating the power of
the story that works so well has no
impact here whatsoever so thankfully
haha the young designer next to me was
Japanese and we struck up a friendship
this we're gonna be together for next
couple days and I'm like I'm have a
problem here I need to translate these
things she's like well I can help you
translate if you want to make any
written material so I designed this
poster overnight this giant poster that
is all in Japanese with pictures of [ __ ]
buns
I had a picture of a stadium seat with
an arrow pointing to it and you know
stadium seats eating in Japanese and
then had somebody kneeling in a garden I
had somebody meditating on it and she
was so kind to translate for me I ran to
Kinkos at night got it printed in
downtown Tokyo and the next day I had
this beautiful poster that did all the
explanation and had demo chair printed
out in Japanese on the demonstrator and
one by one somebody actually made a sale
I was like oh my god okay this is gonna
work and then I had another guy who
actually actually happen to be a RISD
grad who was there just visiting he
spoke Japanese he's like if you want
help translating I'm happy to do this
for you so bless his heart he was
amazing he actually would like draw
people over to my little folding table
with my stacks of [ __ ] buns everywhere
and he would tell this story in Japanese
and I'll never forget the last day it
was like towards the end of the day I
mean he started kind of closing down and
we sold the last pair of curtains and
there's this picture of him and I
sitting there at this empty table being
like oh my god I can't believe we did it
so I was able to pay for my trip
basically able to sell these crib buns
it was just a great lesson and like
having to figure out how to translate
your story beyond just you know English
speakers in my case now that was a row
London experience so man that project
took me all over the place I got to meet
the the guy who invented the foam finger
guy Gerald Foster in Texas to see if he
wanted to manufacture at one point he go
into his Lobby he's got like the
original foam finger from the 1970s in
the glass case right
totally random I got to meet the late
Billy Mays
oh yeah infomercials OxiClean so I
applied it with many many more yeah hey
Billy Mays well show you this right now
and there was a reality show at one
point for inventors and people that made
products and for some reason I was
inspired to submit [ __ ] buns and so I
flew to LA one one weekend
and I'm in this like Lobby for the
casting with all these other inventors
and everybody like really weird stuff
like I'll have stuff for cats
I feel like cats running around I mean
like that's like a lot of pet stuff
there's me like in one of my best shirts
holding my crib buttons like really
proud and the producer comes over and
they mic me up and they're like okay we
want you to walk down that hallway and
go through those double doors and that's
all they said and so I'm like okay so I
got my products proud entrepreneur here
I walked down the hallway statistic dark
the lights are off this dark hallway all
we can see is like these two illuminated
doors at the end and I opened the doors
and they're this huge conference table
is Billy Mays and one other co-star and
then there's like all these cameras and
all these lights pointed at you it was
hey I'm Billy Mays come on in and I sit
down in the chair and suddenly I'm on
this like pitch session it was like
shark tank before shark tank right right
like I'm having to pitch him on why my
products so great and it wasn't going so
well until he tried it out any like how
she got up and he sat down before he
goes oh yeah this is pretty good
and then they said okay thanks and like
I walked it's like it's like blitz of
like five minutes of just pitch mode and
I was like getting peppered with all
these questions and all these lights on
you in this cameras I did not get on the
show but it was just one of these crazy
moments of like these unexpected things
that this product these experiences
that's probably brought me see soon why
are you not why are you not the the
Titan of the crib buns Empire why did
you stop so [ __ ] buns this goes back to
RISD I switched from being in painting
to being into industrial design largely
in part because I learned about Charles
and Ray Eames two designers from the mid
20th century that were a couple raves to
the wife Charles as the husband and they
produced design that it's legendary it's
still referenced today it's in the it's
in the MoMA and the permanent collection
its iconic and they dedicated their
lives to producing the best design to
the most people for the least price
and they were really celebrated for
democratizing good design and making it
accessible I had also had that the chair
project for the carriage Jones and fell
in love with making things and realized
that I wanted to switch from you know
this more creative pursuit of painting
which was more about you know the
expression of ideas through that medium
into the expression of ideas through
industrial design which was cool to me
because you can make something objects
and they could be replicated thousands
hundreds thousands millions of times you
could actually touch millions of people
with your designs just like the Eames
head and so this was my motivation to
switch into gestural design you could
use design to improve people's lives and
they could be done at scale you could
touch a lot of people all at once and so
RISD in the industrial design department
did something brilliant our first year
in the program they put us all in the
school vans and they drove us out to the
Rhode Island State landfill and here we
are driving through these canyons of
trash like you have your faces pressed
up against the bus window and you can't
even see to the top Wow of the landfill
for for the state and you get it out to
the top and your you get out of the vans
and you're looking back over this just
you know landscape of garbage and for me
it hit me like a ton of bricks I'm like
wow like I do not want to spend my life
making things that contributes to making
the landfill better bigger that is not
interesting to me it was like a really
impactful moment where I just I I
started to feel a slight sense of guilt
that I was now studying a discipline
that was about making more stuff and so
it really kicked off this enthusiasm or
consciousness around how do you make
stuff that's environmentally considered
cradle to cradle cradle to cradle yeah I
built McDonough's book which also came
out around this time it was hugely
difficult influential national capitals
and kind of came around honest
these they're starting to be this this
other way of thinking about how we
consume things in the planet and
certainly I've you feel a responsibility
as a designer because you're pretty
close to the origins of those things
sometimes you don't decide the strategy
of hey we need to make this product but
you're definitely in it in the fuel the
view of being able to decide what kind
of materials to use what's the whole
lifecycle of a product and so with kripp
buns I actually delayed the launch of
that for six months because I was trying
to find a foam that was environmentally
considered and I called everybody I I
was talking to people in the Midwest
making foam out of soybeans at one point
I found a woman in England who started
to make plastic had a bubblegum that
you'd scrape off at the sidewalk but I
couldn't find anybody that made a foam
that was perfect for the product so I
decided to go forward the product and
that sparked this other idea which was
okay I've learned two things from this a
the foam doesn't exist and B there
wasn't even a good source to try to find
the foam in the first place mm-hmm right
like Amazon was starting to really
emerge at this time and it was so easy
to find a book on Amazon or like content
I was like why isn't there a site where
you can find sustainable materials I
talked to some my classmates that we had
graduate at this point and became very
clear that whether you're in
architecture or fashion design or
package design or industrial design
there was a growing consciousness around
we want to feel good about the things
that we're making and so I realized no
I'm not a material scientist maybe I'm
not going to invent the foam however I
know how to make a website so what if I
started a site that would allow any
designer to connect with the sources of
single materials but there's bioplastics
or you know reclaimed glass or you know
organic cotton and so a classmate and I
am partnered up together buddy named
Matt and we created this website to help
solve our own problem of having access
to sustainable materials
and you know the site started and it was
this combination of ecology and
intellect so we called it eco X and it
was basically Google for sustainable
materials and we find manufacturers
around the world and we plug them into
the system and I was basically like a
really high-end search engine and
community for people who cared about
this topic so slowed down crypt buns to
work on this website you know the thing
is that the the product remained I had
figured out manufacturing abroad the
Crippen's website was up is getting
press at this point from around the
world it's getting blogged about
shipping orders out of my garage this at
this point it moved to San Francisco my
garage became Crippen's headquarters and
it got into some of the big catalogs in
the US was called solutions catalog she
went out to like I don't know hundreds
of thousands of homes and I had these
orders flowing in like my garage I had
to employ some friends to come help pack
up coupons these orders of hundreds at a
time it was insane great learning
experience and you know in fact him
there's something I brought for you
today oh my god [ __ ] puns for you my
friend
amazing this is incredible thank you so
much oh my God look at this very open
[ __ ] buns a seat cushion for artists and
designers for the love of the crit then
on the back we've got buns TM these buns
approved for use on hard surfaces buns
not a life-saving floatation device good
good note they're intended solely for
cheek to cheek comfort amazing thank you
you get the story on the back yeah oh
yeah here we go the [ __ ] buns story
hours of critiquing from the cold hard
dirty floor give a young design student
more than a sore bum provided the
inspiration for a better way : a seat
cushion offering day-long comfort and
cleaner pants to art students worldwide
the name in shape they originated from
the charcoal bun prints students
behind on metal stools and hardwood
floors dub-dub-dub Crippen's dot-com the
term krit slang for critique is the
presentation of students artwork before
professors and peers and is a staple of
every Art and Design School experience
wait a minute my favorite part so you
got pad spending trademark and copyright
2005 zero sex juice Studios LLC
critiqued in USA all rights reserved
drop us a line highbrow at [ __ ] buns
calm printed with soy ink approved by
the CBB OD I don't know what that is and
then you have a bun shape barcode on the
back for scanning this is a great man I
can see how that chairs already pretty
soft it is already pretty soft
I think I'll I will save this for my
traveling hard surface experience thank
you you're very welcome
so [ __ ] buns sort is slowing down but um
it's funny every so often I still get an
order I still go down to the garage
still still I might still pack it up and
ship it out and you know the wife's
changed quite a bit since then but it's
a great reminder for me of like those
early days and I'm just hustling I'm
trying to get stuff done of like the
enthusiasm and the exuberance of
bringing an idea to life like it was a
rush and then you go from physical to
digital what did you learn from the II
collect experience well II collect
launched at a time and this might be
hard to understand now but if you go
back 10 plus years around 2007 web 2.0
what's happening on the internet and
revenue is not cool right it's crazy the
new economy web see point of revenue was
a cool eyeballs were cool traffic was
great but revenue didn't matter and so
unfortunately we subscribe to that as
well bedico act and our service is free
and
we didn't make any money on it we
bootstrapped the whole thing and never
took investment on it and the one thing
that we did innovate on that actually
didn't make money for us is we called
the green box and the green box was
basically a physical magazine that we
shipped out on a quarterly basis that
allowed people to build an actual
materials library for themselves so we'd
sit ship actual samples with these
beautifully designed placards that gave
you all the information about it with a
special integrated hook so you can
imagine a whole wall of materials that
you'd have in your design studio or your
design team in house or consultancy
whatever the thing was are even at
design school for materials librarian
and that did all right except it was so
laborious I'd be down in the garage like
zip tying things together and design all
these cards and then get the stickers
and like it just it took way too long
verses on how much we made and so around
this time I also have a day job what's
your day job my day job was I got a
fellowship from a book publisher called
Chronicle Books yes and they had a
fellowship which is a six-month program
for recent graduates typically for
graphic designers they introduced one
for industrial designers I'm thinking oh
my god this is perfect
I've got a graphic design background as
well Chronicle makes beautiful beautiful
books their books are like objects right
they really what I learned there was
about the importance of detail and craft
now by fellowship I mean that sounds
like you're given a stipend to pursue
your art but are you also it was like a
glorified intern glorified intern okay
much more attractive when you call it
fellowship it is much more desirable and
it worked and I got that role for six
months and had a great time there really
got to work along since and world-class
graphic design so that's how you're
paying the bills while you're offering
this free service and I eventually get a
full-time offer and I take it and so I'm
there June industrial design work
working on on packaging for for high-end
books so they did the book for George
Lucas on Star Wars and I got to design
the you know the really high-end
okay so this book was huge like you know
I was like 20 pounds it's like one of
those really thick coffee table books
did package for Hugh Hefner he did a
book on the centerfolds every centerfold
since 1954 I believe starting with
Marilyn Monroe and so I got to design
this custom leather briefcase that this
book came in and with the blind and boss
of the Playboy bunny on the front anyway
there's a lot of cool projects there but
a certain point
II collect was growing and I realized it
needed more my full-time efforts and so
I made a decision I said you know I need
to either stick with this job which is
getting very comfortable at that time or
I need to take this plunge into really
doing the startup full-time and so I
quit my job 2007-2008 and around this
time the rent goes up in our apartment
and it's around this time that my former
classmate Brian Chesky moves in with me
to be my roommate and this is
foreshadowing another major event in my
life but we won't get there just yet
all right so make this plunge of
stepping into II collect and [ __ ] buns
now all this while I'm now living in San
Francisco and the thing is since high
school since the first calm when I was
living in Atlanta I would come home
every day and I would be enthralled at
the stories that I was reading about of
all these Internet companies that were
starting you had you know eBay and
Amazon and Yahoo and excite calm and
Lycos and like there was so much
entrepreneurial spirit and I had this I
had the sense that one day I wanted to
run my own thing I didn't know what it's
gonna be maybe was a gallery or
something who knows if it was like what
kind of business it would be and so
Chronicle was my path out to San
Francisco which is where I always wanted
to be because that first com all paths
led back to the Bay Area oh for sure
right and I'm like well that seems to be
the place to go if you want to get an
idea off the ground and so I finally
move out there I bring coupons with me
bring the Eco X concept with me I'm
living in San Francisco and during RISD
I had this this radar on in the back of
my mind that people that I met with
friends at I made I sort of like trying
to find somebody else who had similar
aspirations that I didn't somebody else
who may want to co-found somebody with
me in the future one day and I could be
a partner in a business of some kind and
so at the end of RISD there were very
short was the people that I felt I would
just absolutely love to start something
with the guy at the top of the list was
this guy named Brian Chesky we got to
know each other through sports on campus
because I ran in the basketball team
he ran the hockey team so we got to know
each other via sports and there was one
project that we had together in
industrial design where it was for a
client in the hair care space and we got
to reinvent hair care products like blow
dryers and curling irons and for the
final presentation Brian and I went in
with this team and our concepts were so
wildly different than everybody else's
that I remember looking and being like
wow like this guy when we're in a room
together we can do really creative
things and as the year went on and
before we graduated I just had this
growing feeling that like there's
something special about this guy he knew
how to rally people together he knew how
to get them excited he had his own
project around fitness that he got
people to volunteer their time to help
to do design on and marketing on and I
just remember being really inspired by
him and it's the night before graduation
he's about to move to Los Angeles I'm
about to know I was gonna stay in
Providence working on [ __ ] buns and I
decided to invite him out to dinner to
tell him how I feel about this and so
over a slice of pizza on Thayer Street I
tell him I'm bright like O'Brien I just
want you to know I think we're gonna
start a company one day I think they're
gonna write a book about it and he kind
of laughed it off huh yeah yeah and he
ends up going on Los Angeles I end up
finding my way to San Francisco via
Chronicle Books and very quickly once
I'm in San Francisco
recognize that it is in fact an
epicenter for entrepreneurship there's
so much activity going on around me web
2.0 is like the web is back and I'm
start calling him like Brian I know
what's going on in LA but you could get
up here like there's so much activity so
much action happening here I was like
yeah yeah I got some stuff going and
like this one for at least a year I'm
trying to recruit and get up to San
Francisco and so at a certain point the
roommates that I was living with move
out and I'm left with this three-bedroom
apartment and I call him like Brian I've
got a room available it's now or never
if you're gonna move this is the perfect
window to come up here I've got a room
waiting for you with your name on it and
I have to give him wanted credit he made
a courageous move he quit his job he
packed his life into his Honda Civic and
he drove from Los Angeles to San
Francisco it became a remit a half toy
Tim there was this incredible excitement
in the air like it's like the band was
back together all right
what are we gonna do like what could we
possibly create together and this is the
same week that I quit my job at
Chronicle I've got Crippen's me collect
in the background we're gonna come up
with something big together Brian and I
and that's when I opened the mail one
day that same week he arrives it's a
letter from my landlord and it says dear
Joe your rent is now 25% higher and I
run my online bank account and I see
that I shouldn't have enough money in
the bank because I have no paychecks
coming in to make rent brian has the
same problem and suddenly our backs are
against the wall this is like this dark
stormy cloud that forms over our
apartment Bobby hasn't gone now it's
just terror and fear how are we not
gonna get evicted next month pretty to
make the rent check and that's what I'm
sitting in in my living room one day
that week I've got my laptop open and
I'm looking at the website for a design
conference for industrial designers
coming to San Francisco you know two
weeks later and it says in big red
letters hotels are sold out in San
Francisco I'm thinking oh man what a
bummer if somebody wants to come
last-minute they've got nowhere to stay
and I glanced over that the top of the
laptop screen into the vast space of the
living room
and start to think what if I pull my air
bed out of the closet and blow it up on
the floor we could host the designer for
less than the cost of hotel and maybe
make some money to make our rent check
so I email Bryan and he loves the idea
we actually get two more air beds and we
start to think through this experience
what if we offered Airport pick-up what
if we gave them a map to San Francisco
and a BART pass at the subway and we
cook them breakfast in the morning and
so we created this concept called the
air bed and breakfast we made a website
air bed and breakfast comm it was four
pages pictures of us pictures of the air
beds we talked about the neighborhood
and we were so proud of our website
except who the hell on earth knew to go
to air bed and breakfast no no but not
exactly a high-volume
search term right so one night we
realized that we have a marketing
problem the conference is coming up
pretty quick you got the word out so we
email the design blogs the top design
blogs that were covering the conference
and neither of us had really been on
design box before other than eco acts
and crib buns
and it was kind of a Hail Mary we just
sent these emails out to like press tips
at link com the next morning we came
down we open our computers in timid feel
like Christmas there we were at the top
of the design blogs with headlines like
need a place for the conference sticks
this weekend crash with Joe and Brian
and there's some loft but amazing I was
like networking your Jam Jam is on the
air bed of breakfast and this idea that
we had you know a week or two earlier
was now being blogged about to the world
in the design community it's so they
responded we the emails from all over
the world from Brazil from England from
Japan of people dying to have one of
these air beds in our living rooms
people started sending us their LinkedIn
profiles in the design portfolios and
the resume
being like trying to convince us to pick
them to be one of the lucky three guests
amazing at one point my phone rings with
an area code that was unfamiliar I
didn't answer it it's only have a
voicemail I'm listening to the voicemail
and it's this guy named Amol who's
telling me he's going my name is Amol
and I just saw the air bed and breakfast
concept and I have to stay with you guys
call me back I I have to stay at the
Airbender breakfast here's my phone
number and then in my inbox I've got
like two emails from this guy I'm like
how did he find me information um so I
call him back and he sends his design
portfolio checks out he's you know a
grad student at Arizona State University
studying industrial design and he
becomes our first guest and then we
accept two other people one woman named
Kat another gentleman named Michael all
were over the age of 30 Kat was a single
soul traveler from Boston Michael was a
45 year old husband and father of five
from Utah and there was a lot of
excitement when the guests arrived it's
like you know we made sure the bet the
air beds were properly inflated there
was a mint on the pillow like we cleaned
the place up in advance we stocked the
fridge with OJ and bagels and you know
fresh eggs and we had everything ready
to go I have to tell you Tim the next
couple of nights were just some of the
most exciting because this thing
unfolded that we didn't expect which is
that yeah we made some money on it but
more than that week we became friends
with them and we really got to show them
San Francisco through the lens of of us
there were our favorite things to do our
favorite places to eat it's imagine the
difference of this you're at a
conference and at the end of the day you
can retire by yourself to a hotel room
that maybe is so much generic or lacks
and general personality or you they came
back to our apartment which was Lively
we're cooking dinner together they're
sharing stories from our days at the
conference it was like night and day for
them and they had such a good experience
we took them to her friend's house
parties after the conference some nights
we took him to the best burritos in the
Mission District to the the farmers
market at the Ferry Building one morning
and at one point we gave her a place to
take visitors it's very building there
was a patch Akkad should talk during the
conference
who'sa whoa huh yeah what socket it's
that it's at that format where you have
20 sides and in like four minutes
I've right and so I just move and you
got to give a quick orientation and so
we gave a presentation about air
bed-and-breakfast in the moment that
we're hosting people on air bed and
breakfast and we had our guests up there
with us and talked about this concept
that came together you know two weeks
ago is now actually unfolding in front
of us right now and it was just like
really meta moment where the guests are
now part of the presentation about
themselves and it was totally insane
let's step five of the crypt buns
aka Airbnb sales process here the story
so I'll never forget when saying goodbye
to them the door click closed and I look
at Bryan and I'm like did we just get
paid to make friends and that Tim is
when the gears began to turn maybe there
were other people like us who also enjoy
sharing their extra space with people
coming to their town and want want a
local experience and so we told my
previous remain Nate who I found on
Craigslist he was a computer science
graduate from Harvard who when he moved
out Bryan moved into his room and now
Nate storey with him is we lived
together for a couple of months and at
night we come home from our day jobs and
we would work on our own projects in the
living room I was working on crypt bones
they was working on his own startups and
it was remarkable I'm looking over my
shoulder thinking wow this guy loves to
work we have similar work ethics and I'm
like if I ever need a computer
programmer I'm gonna call on Nate
little did I know that Nate was saying
the same thing about me designer McCall
and Jo so Nate moves out Bryan moves in
and after this one weekend yeah a couple
months actually passed and we didn't
move on the concepts we went home for
New Year's that year this is 2007
so it happened in October we come from
New Year's in 2007 and in there
invariably people ask you hey how's it
going what are you working on what's
going on in San Francisco
all right we're entrepreneurs and they
go great what do you entrepreneur he and
I didn't really have a lot going on
Crippen's is kind of their Eclipse kind
of you know struggling along there's no
funding at this point but I did tell
people about this crazy weekend were
these three guests sleep on the air beds
in her apartment and it was remarkable
what happened next
people either leaned in and went oh my
god that's amazing
I would love to travel and stay with a
local and the other half of people went
oh my god you're crazy you had a
stranger in your home what were you
thinking and this like visceral reaction
that the cause people in these
conversations was like wow like this
really gets people fired up in either
direction maybe there's something here
so Brian and we come back in January
Brian comes back he's from New York
upstate he comes back and we had similar
experiences he's like yeah I told people
about and they either loved it or hated
it and we're like yeah like maybe we
maybe this is the idea that we should
expand on so we're like okay we know we
need a real programmer so I'm like wow
I'm gonna call him Natan so get a drink
with Nate I tell him about this crazy
weekend with these three guests Nate
loves the idea he's like wait we can use
the internet to get people offline back
into the real world with each other it's
like I would love to spend my time on
this so at this point we think the big
opportunity is a website for conferences
for people to sleep on air beds and
living rooms this turns out as a very
narrow market we do not know this at the
time so our logical next step is what's
the next big conference coming up where
hotels will sell out well turns out that
right here in Austin every March it's
quite a large conference called South by
Southwest it also happens to be the
place where some preeminent tech
companies went to launch and took off
like rocket ships including Foursquare
and Twitter and some others
what year was this 2008 so we're like
we're gonna build the next version for
South by Southwest and there's gonna
take off just like the others so Nate
hunkers down with us we start to code
out the next more robust version of the
site becomes more than just four pages
and we pull all nighters for like two
weeks and we launched just in time for
South by Southwest and all this
excitement all this energy Tim we got a
total of five hosts two reservations
yeah I'm the mathematician but that
ratio doesn't sound favorable well one
of the reservations was us it's actually
Brian and Brian stayed with this guy
here in Austin named Tim Dunn and he had
everything laid out and he had the
pillow and the towels and the mints need
some like some super cooking in the
background he was a great hosts right
he's taking really seriously you know at
this time would like you it was just a
classified service right you came and he
paid somebody on arrival and Brian Brian
tells the story that he forgot to go to
the ATM machine and so he gets there and
he goes through the whole night and
wakes up the next day and the host has
to awkwardly ask him by the way where's
my money
Isaac oh no she forgot go to the ATM
today
Brian forgets got the ATM another night
goes by that's my the host is like what
kind of joke is this these guys just
make a website to freeload
accommodations and they travel and so
Brian eventually got to the ATM and paid
him but he said that that experience was
incredibly awkward paying somebody cash
in person inside their home is like just
not a great experience so afterwards you
know it was not a successful launch
whatsoever I think we got one mention on
Mashable like it was dismal and we
debrief and the whole thing and we we
realized two things because
we're getting emails from people who are
like hey I want to stay in a home but
there's no conference in the city how do
I use your service and so we realized
something well maybe this is more than a
conference website made this is just a
travel website and what if we got rid of
the awkwardness of payments in person
and allowed people to pay with a credit
card in advance online and we just
removed that whole awkwardness from the
customer experience and in doing so
we're like what if we did the Train at
the transaction online we could take a
small transaction fee and a business
model was born and so at this point
naita needed a little bit more
enthusiasm to get back involved in in in
the concept of the three of us we all
balanced each other out really well
Nate's the pragmatist of all three of us
so he you know helps ground us in
reality in progress and shipping things
while sometimes Brian and I can be have
her head in the clouds and really dream
it's a perfect balance and Nate needs
some convincing that this can actually
work so in the summer of 2008 we
realized that we could use some kind of
event to give this thing a spark for
this thing to take off and if you
remember back in 2008 what everybody was
talking about especially in the
summertime the year of a presidential
election John McCain versus Barack Obama
and Obama was attracting these historic
record-breaking crowds he spoke in
Portland a 75,000 people and it was
identified in June that the DNC the
Democratic National Convention later
that August there was going to be a bit
of a problem because they moved the
venue from the basketball arena of
20,000 seats to Invesco stadium which
had a hundred thousand seats to attract
more people to come to Denver to see
Obama speak therein lies a problem with
the amount of housing that exists in
Denver they have 20,000 hotel rooms most
of them were already taken up by
delegates and the headlines started to
read housing crisis impending on Denver
the mayor started hold press conferences
to say he might open the city parks for
people to pitch tents because there was
no word asleep so we recognize and say
wait what if we really launched in time
for the DNC so we can ride the coattails
of all this press to gain an awareness
for our the next iteration of air bed
and breakfast so Nate loved the idea we
hunker down we spend the summer
rebuilding the site with online payments
and the ability to travel anywhere at
any time so this was the carrot for Nate
was this Nate needed to know that there
was some reliable you know mechanism to
create awareness on the horizon because
to build a marketplace without any
awareness is like you know difficult to
the least difficult to say Louise so we
hit the ground in Denver we I remember
we built a web site this shiny new
version of air bed and breakfast and we
get on the phone with press trying to
pitch him like we had no idea we were
doing I'm on the phone with see it like
CNN and they basically hang up on me but
I have experience with that from some
other projects that I've cast some like
I'm just gonna keep going and SW secured
post W C equals I mouth beautiful so
what we learned what we started to do is
actually contact local bloggers in
Denver like CNN is not gonna answer a
call but a local blogger
loved this story because it was of their
neighborhoods and was very human
oriented of Denver residents opening
their homes to support other fellow
Obama supporters and so these blogs did
write about it and it turns out that's
where like the newspapers looking for
story ideas
so the newspapers wrote about it and
turns out that's where the local TV
broadcast looks for story ideas so then
we got a call from NBC local affiliate
and when NBC does a story CBS and ABC
what we follow so then we have you got
the Denver press covered it turns out
that's what the boulder press looks to
you for story ideas and B started to
become a regional story and turns out
when you have regional story that's what
CNN looks to for story ideas so within a
matter of about two to three weeks we
went from zero listings in Denver to 800
people sharing their homes Wow just
through this awareness through press
again we had no money
like there was can hire like a PR firm
we can like go buy online ads like this
is all just word of mouth like the press
talking about us and then we get the
call from CNN and there's this funny
moment where Brian and I are doing a
live interview in our living room on a
laptop through like Skype or something
and we have we're sharing like ear buds
were conjoined to each other because
we're sitting so close everything
there's a live interview of this guy
Errol Barnett on CNN and talking about
this website and what it means to people
to be able to stay in a home for anybody
go into the DNC and it was and then we
need have a CNN story that's what
international press look to to create
stories then LeMond picks us up in The
Guardian and press out in Europe and
it's just amazing to see what happens
when an idea or a story starts at the
smallest nugget and works its way up
this chain right after becoming an
international story in a matter of three
or so weeks amazing you know I have to
give credit to to Seth Godin because I
remember during Crippen's I read his
book all marketers are liars and I
remember something that he says in there
which I never forgot which is to make
something people want to talk about
right it's like Purple Cow it's like
make something that's distinct enough
that people want to talk about it that's
differentiated enough and I feel like
that concept was imbued into like the
early days of the company certainly into
[ __ ] buns and II collect and definitely
into air bed and breakfast at the time
and certainly if I watched it happen in
front of me making something people want
to talk about go from a local Denver
blogger story to International Press who
is it safe to say would you consider
that the the first or one of the first
major successful milestones for air bed
and breakfast yes because we had a few
hundred people staying on the site that
weekend including us we got to go to
Denver Sunday was busy yeah it was
really busy so we had divided
responsibilities just three of us Nate's
doing all the coding Bryan's handling
all the press and I'm handling all the
design and the customer service yeah so
let me hit pause and let me
ask you would it make sense and we can
we can certainly decide on the fly here
but we've got about my guy close to
three hours would it make sense to have
this be part one and then follow up with
a part two Oh what do you think of that
we don't have to we don't have to but we
could what are your thoughts I'm open to
it and then record another time yeah I'm
just thinking like this is you totally
yeah we people the cliffhanger this is I
think this is a good cliffhanger okay so
then I'll say yeah okay go no no no no
go for it yeah however I mean because
this like this deserves around two so we
had so we had a few hundred people
actually using the service Brian and I
split up responsibilities Nate doings
coding Brian's new inhale the press I'm
doing all the customer service from my
cell phone and we have this incredible
weekend where our marketplace is working
but you won't imagine what happens next
whoo dot dot dot okay amazing no this is
perfect
this is absolutely perfect uh so to be
continued in the meantime as sort of a
temporary tie-up of part one is there
anything that you would like people to
take from this this first chronology
that we've walked people through any ask
of the audience recommendation
suggestion that you would like parting
words of any type I think anytime that
you introduce a new idea into the world
there's there's bound to be somebody or
many people who reject it
so I think rejection is inevitable any
time you're trying something new in fact
I'd say if you're not getting rejected
you're probably not trying anything like
you probably not even pushing hard
enough on something new and my advice
would be will get rejection in a
different way that equation for me was
it was just a way to reframe rejection
as an opportunity to keep going move on
and so my advice for everybody watching
is that you know the gift of an
entrepreneur is to reframe things and
anytime there's a rejection that you
face turned it into an invitation turn
it into an invitation to keep going and
you can say yes or no you don't have to
be at least create this opportunity to
to persevere to continue going forward
and for me every all the stories I've
shared so far from the senior prank with
the intercom system through to [ __ ]
buttons through to the beginnings of
Airbnb are reframing every know into a
cool that person didn't like it I'm
gonna keep going till I find somebody
that does and also something at least
that I see from the outside looking in
when you're sharing all of these stories
and experiences is that you are also
over time by exposing yourself to
rejection and reframing learning to in
some ways seek out discomfort as opposed
to avoid discomfort and that that's one
thing that also comes up for me and on
top of that the fact that and why I am
so excited that we were able to get
together to talk about some of these
many of these stories which is of course
just a portion of your many life
experiences is that people are already
familiar at this point with Arab Airbnb
and all caps right magazine covers one
of the most successful startups in the
world one of the fastest growing stars
of all time etc etc etc and I think it's
it's easy because as humans we want to
take shortcuts and create stories that
are easily graspable to think of that as
idea execute success well it just came
out of the balloon was his overnight
success but there's so much contributing
to that and so many diverse experiences
that yes you had but in some ways you
also helped to engineer and I think
that's inspiring right to know that it
wasn't it wasn't the byproduct of this
immaculate master
and that required you to be Elon Musk
times 10 that you executed over a
two-week period and then you have an
empire no that's not that's not how it
unfolds at all if people think we woke
up and err be immediate was just created
out of thin air that couldn't be further
from the truth and I hope if any there's
any takeaway from the stories that we've
talked about today is that there's just
a long lineage of trying things bumping
into walls getting rejected like failing
reframing that failure into learning and
trying to continue forward and so by the
time
Airbnb came around it was like I'd been
in the gym of entrepreneurship for many
years so it's like you don't wake up and
just run a marathon all of a sudden that
nobody does that you trained for it and
so by the time it's ready for race day
your body's conditioned for it and your
muscles in your system you're like
everything's ready it's for you to go
run 26 plus miles and I think
entrepreneurs entrepreneurship is the
exact same way and I think it's a
misconception when people look at the
magazine covers and they read it but the
stories of a successful company they
think wow like the people have started
that it just they built it and everybody
came that couldn't be further from the
truth
and like I think fuel the dreams is
probably the worst movie to ever happen
entrepreneurship because you created
this idea like oh wow if you build it
they will come I can tell you if you
build it they don't come and it it it
takes this incredible perseverance and
sometimes it rational belief in yourself
to bring something to life in the face
of a lot of adversity and a lot of
people saying it can't happen and so I
hope if there's any takeaway from the
stories that I shared today it's that
the simple act of spotting an
opportunity coming up with the original
solution and then taking that third but
hardest step of putting something into
the world of trying something putting
your idea into practice it doesn't have
to be the big idea it's just about being
in the gym and doing a rap the gym of
entrepreneurship you're doing like a
curls or something like it's just
getting in the habit of those three
things you spot an opportunity you come
up with original solution and you put
your idea into the world and the more
you can do that the better you are at
spotting the next opportunity
and Airbnb just happened to be a part of
the lineage of all the things I've told
you to happen before it this can you lay
out the equation one more time and what
each letter stands for absolutely SW
squared plus WC equals M oh and what the
stands for is that when you introduce a
new idea to the world some will love it
some moult plus who cares equals move on
keep going until you find the people
that do love your idea all right Joe
amazing where can people say hi to you
online find you where can they learn
more about the company and anything else
you might want to mention I'd say go to
air be me calm and if you want to
connect with me you can follow along at
on Instagram at Joe Gibbs go get on
Twitter at Jay Gibeah and certainly [ __ ]
bones is out there too and for everybody
who's watching listening we will have
links to [ __ ] buns Joe Gibbs and all
affiliated links resources and so on for
everything we talked about in the show
notes as per usual at tim dot blog
forward slash podcast thank you
everybody for listening and joe thanks
for hanging in so much fun super fun Tim
thanks for having me dot dot dot
to be continued to be continued